- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science,
and science based tools
for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today we are discussing memory.
In particular, how to improve your memory.
Now the study of memory
is one that dates back
many decades, and by now there's
a pretty good understanding
of how memories are formed in the brain.
The different structures involved
and some of the neuro chemicals involved.
And we will talk about some of that today.
Often overlooked,
however, is that memories
are not just about learning.
Memories are also about
placing your entire life
into a context.
And that's because what's
really special about the brain
and in particular the human brain,
is its ability to place
events in the context
of past events, the present,
and future events.
And sometimes even combinations
of the past and present.
Or present and future and so on.
So when we talk about memory
what we're really talking about
is how your immediate experiences relate
to previous and future experiences.
Today I'm going to make clear how
that process occurs.
Even if you don't have a background
in biology or psychology, I promise
to put it into language that anyone
can access and understand.
And we are going to talk about
the science that points to specific tools
for enhancing learning and memory.
We're also going to talk about unlearning
and forgetting.
There are of course incidences in which
we would like to forget things.
And that too is a biological process
for which great tools exist.
To, for instance, eliminate
or at least reduce
the emotional load of
a previous experience
that you really did not like,
or that perhaps even was traumatic to you.
So today you're going to learn
about the systems in the brain and body
that establish memories.
You're going to learn why certain memories
are easier to form than others.
And I'm going to talk about specific tools
that are grounded in not just one,
not just a dozen, but
well over 100 studies
in animals and humans that point
to specific protocols that you can use
in order to stamp down learning
of particular things more easily.
And you can also leverage
that same knowledge
to better forget or unload
the emotional weight
of experiences that you did not like.
We're also going to
discuss topics like deja vu
and photographic memory.
And for those of you that do not
have a photographic memory,
and I should point out that I do not have
a photographic memory, either.
Well, you will learn how to use
your visual system in
order to better learn
visual and auditory information.
There are protocols to do this
grounded in excellent
peer reviewed research.
So while you may not have
a true photographic memory,
by the end of the episode you will
have tools in hand, or I should say,
tools in mind or in eyes and mind,
to be able to encode and
remember specific events
better than you would otherwise.
Before we begin I would like to emphasize
that this podcast is
separate from my teaching
and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress covers
with cooling, heating, and sleep tracking.
Many times on this
podcast I've talked about
the incredible relationship
between temperature and sleep
as well as temperature and wakefulness.
Many people aren't aware of this,
but waking up in the morning is in part
the consequence of your body heating up.
And falling asleep at night
and remaining in deep sleep
is in part the consequence
of your body temperature
dropping by one to three degrees.
So it's vitally important
that the temperature
of your sleeping
environment is controlled.
I've had trouble over the years
falling and staying asleep.
Or I should say, falling
asleep hasn't been
so much of an issue for me,
but waking up two or
three or four hours later
has been an issue.
Often times I'm too warm,
I need to open a window.
I need to adjust the temperature
of the room and so on.
Eight Sleep mattress covers are terrific
because you can program
the specific patterns
of temperature that you want in your bed,
or I should say below you,
coming from the mattress,
throughout the night.
So I've programmed my Eight Sleep
to put my mattress into
a state of coolness
in order to fall asleep.
And then to get slightly
cooler as the night goes on.
To get into even deeper sleep.
And then to warm up as morning approaches.
Now, as mentioned before,
Eight Sleep mattresses
can be used for cooling and heating.
So some of you may actually need
to heat your mattress and Eight
Sleep's terrific for that.
For me, I use Eight Sleep to
keep the mattress really cool.
And I have to say, even though I thought
I was sleeping pretty well before,
I have not experienced the sort of sleep
that I've been getting
with Eight Sleep until now.
By creating this descending temperature
in the beginning part of the night,
cooler, cooler, cooler.
And then warming up towards morning.
It even has a nice
little vibration function
so I wake up now to a
slightly vibrating bed.
And the sleep that I'm
getting is just amazing.
And I feel so much better
during the day as a consequence.
If you'd like to try Eight Sleep
you can go to EightSleep.com/Huberman
and check out the pod pro cover
and save 150 dollars at checkout.
Eight Sleep currently ships within
the USA, Canada, and the UK.
Again, that's EightSleep.com/Huberman
to save 150 dollars at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics.
And to be quite honest, I
don't like the word nootropics.
Because nootropics means smart drugs.
And there really isn't
a neuroscience of smart.
Of course, there is this
notion of intelligence,
but we now know there are lots
of different forms of intelligence.
Also, as a neuroscientist,
we don't really think about intelligence,
we think about those particular types
of operations that you
want your brain to perform
in different contexts.
So for instance, some
tasks and life experiences
require that you remember
information better.
Other tasks and life experiences
and forms of learning involve
focus and task switching.
Others creativity, and so on, and so on.
So the word nootropics is too much
of a catchall or throw away
phrase to appeal to me.
Thesis understands this.
And what they've done is they've created
nootropics that are each designed
toward a particular end goal.
For instance, they have blends for focus.
Blend for motivation.
A blend for clarity.
They use only the highest
quality ingredients.
Things like Alpha GPC
and phosphatidyl serine.
I've been using Thesis for
close to six months now
and I can confidently say their nootropics
have been a game changer for me.
I often take the clarity formula
prior to long bouts of work,
meaning cognitive work.
And the energy formula
prior to physical workouts.
To get your own personalized
nootropics starter kit,
you can go online to
TakeThesis.com/Huberman.
Take the three minute quiz
and Thesis will send you
four different formulas to
try in your first month.
Again, that's TakeThesis.com/Huberman
and use the code Huberman at checkout
to get 10% off your first box.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and DNA
to help you better understand your body
and help you reach your health goals.
I've long been a believer
in getting regular blood work done.
For the simple reason
that many of the factors
that impact your immediate
and long term health
can only be assessed from
a quality blood test.
One of the challenges
with a lot of blood tests
and DNA tests out there, however,
is that you'll get the numbers back.
You'll get information
about your blood lipids
and hormones and so forth.
But there are no directives as to what
to do with that information.
InsideTracker has solved that problem
by creating a very easy to use dashboard.
So you'll get your numbers back
and you see what's in range
and what's out of range.
And then they will point you
to specific nutritional supplementation
and behavioral tools that
will allow you to bring
those numbers into the
proper ranges for you.
And I find that immensely beneficial
because just having a bunch of data
without any knowledge of
what to do with that data
is more overwhelming than
having no data at all, frankly.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can go to InsideTracker.com/Huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
Again, that's InsideTracker.com/Huberman
to get 20% off.
Okay, let's talk about memory.
And let's talk about how to get better
at remembering things.
Now in order to address
both of those things
we need to do a little bit
of brain science 101 review.
And I promise this will
only take two minutes.
And I promise that even if
you don't have a background
in biology, it will make sense.
We are constantly being
bombarded with physical stimuli.
Patterns of touch on our skin,
light to our eyes, light to
our skin, for that matter.
Smells, tastes, and sound waves.
In fact, if you can hear
me saying this right now,
well, that's the
consequence of sound waves
arriving into your ears
through headphones,
a computer, or some other speaker device.
Each one of and all of
those sensory stimuli
are converted into electricity
and chemical signals by your
so-called nervous system.
Your brain, your spinal cord,
and all their connections
with the organs of the body.
And all the connections
of your organs of the body
back to your brain and spinal cord.
One of the primary jobs of
your nervous system, in fact,
is to convert physical events in the world
that are non-negotiable, right?
Photons of light are photons of light.
Sound waves are sound waves.
There's no changing that.
But your nervous system does change that.
It converts those things
into electrical signals
and chemical signals which are
the language of your nervous system.
Now just because you're being bombarded
with all this sensory information
and it's being converted into a language
that neurons and the rest
of your nervous system
can understand, does not mean
that you are aware of it all.
In fact, you are only going to perceive
a small amount of that
sensory information.
For instance, if you can
hear me speaking right now
you are perceiving my
voice but you are also,
most likely, neglecting the feeling
of the contact of your
skin with whichever surface
you happen to be sitting or standing on.
So it is only by perceiving a subset,
a small fraction of the sensory events
in our environment, that we can make sense
of the world around us.
Otherwise we would just be overwhelmed
with all the things that are happening
in any one given moment.
Now memory is simply a bias in which
perceptions will be replayed
again in the future.
Anytime you experience something,
that is the consequence of specific chains
of neurons, that we call neural
circuits, being activated.
And memory is simply a
bias in the likelihood
that specific chain of neurons
will be activated again.
So for instance, if you
can remember your name
and I certainly hope that you can,
well, that means that
there are specific chains
of neurons in your brain
that represent your name
and when those neurons
connect with one another
and communicate electrically
with one another
in a particular sequence,
you remember your name.
Were that particular chain
of neurons to be disrupted,
you would not be able
to remember your name.
Now this might seem immensely simple,
but it raises this really
interesting question
which we've talked about before.
Which is, why do we
remember certain things
and not others?
Because according to what I've just said,
as you go through life,
you're experiencing things all the time.
You're constantly being
bombarded with sensory stimuli.
Some of those sensory
stimuli you perceive,
and only some of those perceptions
get stamped down as memories.
Today I'm going to teach
you how certain things
get stamped down as memories.
And I'm going to teach you how
to leverage that process in order
to remember the information
that you want far better.
Now, even though I've told you
that a memory is simply
a bias in the likelihood
that a particular chain of neurons
will be activated in a particular sequence
again and again, it
doesn't operate on its own.
In fact, most of what
we remember takes place
in a context of other events.
So for instance, you can most
likely remember your name
and yet you're probably not thinking about
when it was that you
first learned your name.
This generally happens when we are very,
very young children.
And yet, I'm guessing you
could probably remember
a time when someone
mispronounced your name,
or made fun of or name.
Or, as the case was for me,
I got to the 3rd grade and
there were two Andrews.
And sadly for me, I lost the coin flip
that allowed me to keep Andrew.
And from about 3rd grade
until about 12th grade
people called me Andy.
Which I really did not prefer.
So if you call me Andy in the comments,
I'll delete your comment.
Just kidding, doesn't bother me that much.
But eventually I reclaimed
Andrew as my name.
Well, it was mine to
begin with and throughout,
but I started going by Andrew again.
Why do I say this?
Well, there's a whole
context to my name for me.
And there may or not be a whole context
to your name for you.
But presumably, if you asked your parents
why they named you your given name,
you'll get a context, etc.
That context reflects the activation
of other neural circuits that are also
related to other events in your life.
Not just your name, but
probably your siblings names
and who your parents are.
And on, and on, and on.
And so, the way memory works is that each
individual thing that we remember
or that we want to remember
is linked to something by either
a close, a medium, or a
very distant association.
This turns out to be immensely important.
I know many of you will read
or will encounter
programs that are designed
to help you enhance your memory.
You know, you have these
phenoms that can remember
50 names in a room full of people.
Or they can remember a bunch
of names of novel objects
or maybe even in different languages,
and often times that's
done by association.
So people will come up
with little mental tricks
to either link the sound of a word
or the meaning of a word in some way
that's meaningful for them
and will enhance their memory.
That can be done and is
impressive when we see it
and for those of you who can
do that, congratulations.
Most of us can't do that,
or at least it requires a
lot of effort and training.
However, there are things that we can do
that leverage the natural biology
of our nervous system to enhance
learning and memory of
particular perceptions,
and particular information.
Let's first just talk about
the most basic ways that we
learn and remember things
and how to improve learning and memory.
And the most basic one is repetition.
Now the study of memory and the role
of repetition actually dates back
to the late 1800s, early 1900s
when Ebbinghaus developed
the first so-called learning curves.
Now learning curves
are simply what results
when you quantify how many repetitions
of something are required in
order to remember something.
In fact, it's been said
that Ebbinghaus liberated
the understanding of learning
from the philosophers
by generating these learning curves.
What do we mean by that?
Well, before Ebbinghaus came along,
learning and memory were thought
to be philosophical ideas.
Ebbinghaus came along and said, well,
let's actually take some measurements.
Let's measure how well I can remember
a sequence of words or
a sequence of numbers
if I just repeat them.
So what Ebbinghaus did is he would
take a sequence of numbers,
or words on a page and he would read them.
And then he would take a
separate sheet of paper.
And we have to presume he didn't cheat,
and he would write down as many of them
as he could and he would try and keep
them in the same sequence.
Then he would compare to the original list
and he would see how many errors he made.
And he would do this over, and over,
and over again.
And as you would expect,
early in the training and the learning
it took a lot more repetitions
to get the sequence correct.
And over time, it took fewer sequences.
And he referred to that difference
in the initial number of repetitions
that he had to perform versus
the later number of repetitions he had
to perform as a so-called savings.
So he literally thought of the brain
as having to generate a kind
of a currency of effort.
And he talked about
savings as the reduction
in the amount of effort that he had
to put forward in order
to learn information.
And what he got was a learning curve.
And you can imagine what that
learning curve looked like.
It had a very sharp peak at the beginning
that dropped off over time.
And of course, he remembered all this
meaningless information.
But even though the information might
have been meaningless,
the experiment itself
and what Ebbinghaus demonstrated
was immensely meaningful.
Because what it said
was that with repetition
we can activate particular
sequences of neurons
and that repeated activation lays down
what we call a memory.
And that might all seem like a big duh,
but prior to Ebbinghaus,
none of that was known.
Now, I should also say Ebbinghaus,
because of when he was alive,
was not aware of these things
that we called neural circuits.
It was in 1906 that Golgi
and Cajal got the Nobel prize
for actually showing that
neurons are independent cells
connected by synapses, these
little gaps between them
where they communicate.
So he may have been aware of that,
but the whole notion of neural circuits
hadn't really come about.
Nevertheless, what the
Ebbinghaus learning curves
really established was
that sheer repetition,
just repeating things over
and over and over again
is sufficient to learn.
Something that no doubt
had been observed before
but had never been formally quantified.
Now, if we look at that result,
there's something really
important that lies
a little bit cryptic, that's
not so obvious to most people.
Which is, the information
that he was trying to learn
wasn't any more
interesting the second time
than it was the first, probably
it was even less interesting
and less and less interesting
with each repetition.
And yet it was sheer repetition
that allowed him to remember.
Now sometime later in
the early to mid 1920s,
a psychologist in Canada named Donald Hebb
came up with what was
called Hebb's postulate.
And Hebb's postulate, broadly speaking,
is this idea that if a sequence of neurons
is active at the same time,
or at roughly the same time,
that would lead to a strengthening
of a connections between those neurons.
And many, many decades
of experimentation later
we now know that postulate to be true.
Neurons themselves are not
smart, they don't have knowledge.
So every memory is the consequence,
as I told you before, of
the repeated activation
of a particular chain of neurons.
And what Ebbinghaus
showed through repetition
and what Donald Hebb proposed
and was eventually verified
through experimentation
on animals and humans
was that if you encourage
the co-activation of neurons.
Meaning have neurons fire
at roughly the same time,
they will strengthen their connections.
It leads to a bias in the probability
that those neurons will be active again.
Now, this is vitally
important because nowadays
we hear a lot about how
memories are the consequence
of new neurons added into the brain.
Or that every time you learn something,
a new connection in your brain forms.
Well, sorry to break it to you,
but that's simply not the case.
Most of the time, and I
want to emphasize most,
not all but most of the
time when we learn something
it's because existing
neurons, not new neurons,
but existing neurons
strengthen their connections
through co-activation
over and over and over.
Through repetition or, and
this is a very important or,
or through very strong
activation once and only once.
In fact, there's something
called one trial learning
whereby we experience something
and we will remember that thing forever.
This is often most associated
with negative events,
and I'll explain why in a few minutes.
But it can also be associated
with positive events.
Like the first time you
saw your romantic partner.
Or something that happened
with that romantic partner.
Or the first time that you saw your child.
Or any other positive
event, as well as any other
extremely negative event.
So again, both repetition, and I guess
we could label it intensity.
But what we really mean
when we say intensity
is strong activation
of neurons can lay down
these traces, these circuits
that are far more likely
to be active again, than had
there not been repetition
or not some strong
activation of those circuits.
So with that in mind, let's
return to the original
contrarian question that I raised before.
Which is, why do we remember anything?
Everyday you wake up, your neurons
in your brain and body are active.
Different neural circuits are active.
And yet, you only
remember a small fraction
of the things that happen each day.
And yet, you retain a lot of information
from previous days and the
days before those and so on.
It is only with a lot of repetition
or with extremely strong activation
of a given neural circuit that
we will create new memories.
And so in a few minutes I'll explain how
to get extremely strong activation
of particular neural circuits.
Repetition is pretty obvious.
Repetition is repetition.
But in a few minutes I'll illustrate
a whole set of experiments and a whole set
of tools that point to how you can get
extra strong activation
of a given neural circuit
as it relates to learning so that you will
remember that information,
perhaps not just
with one trial of learning,
but certainly with far fewer repetitions
than would be required otherwise.
Before we go any further I want to preface
the discussion by saying
that there are a lot of
different kinds of memory.
In fact, were you to take a voyage
into the neuroscience, and
or psychology of memory
you would find an immense number
of different terms to describe
the immense number of different types
of memory that researchers focus on.
But for the sake of today's discussion,
I really just want to
focus on short term memory,
medium term memory, and longterm memory.
And while there is still debate,
as is always the case
with scientists, frankly,
about the exact divisions between
short term, medium, and longterm memory,
we can broadly define short term memory
and longterm memory.
And we can describe a
couple different types
of those that I think you can relate to
in your everyday life.
The most common form of short term memory
that we're going to focus
on is called working memory.
Working memory is your ability to keep
a chain of numbers in mind
for some period of time
but the expectation really isn't
that you would remember
those numbers the next day
and certainly not the next week.
So a good example would be a phone number.
If I were to tell ya a phone number,
493-2938, well you could
probably remember it.
493-2938.
But if I came back tomorrow and asked you
to repeat that chain of numbers,
most likely you would not.
Unless, of course, we
used a particular tool
to stamp down that memory into your mind
and commit it to longterm memory.
Now of course, in this day in age,
most people have phone numbers
programmed into their phone
and they don't really have to
remember the exact numbers.
It's usually done by contact
identity and so forth.
So a different example that some of you
are probably more familiar with
would be those security codes.
So you try and log unto
an app or a website
and it asks you for a security code
that's been sent to your text messages
and you can either plug that in directly
in some cases, or you have to remember
that short sequence of anywhere usually
from six to seven,
sometimes eight numbers.
Your ability to do that,
to switch back and forth
between web pages or apps
and plug in that number
by remembering the sequence
and plugging it in,
by texting or keying
it in on your keyboard,
that's a really good
example of working memory.
Longterm memory, of the sort that we're
going to be talking a lot about today
is your ability to commit certain patterns
of information, either
cognitive information
or motor information.
Right, the ability to move your limbs
in a particular sequence.
Over long periods of time.
Such that you could remember it a day,
or a week, or a month,
or maybe even a year
or several years later.
So we've got short term
memory and longterm memory.
And we've got this working memory
which is sort of keeping something online
but then discarding okay.
Not online on a computer,
but online within your brain.
There are also two major
categories of memory
that I'd like you to know about.
One is explicit memory.
So this is not necessarily explicit
of the sort that you're
used to thinking about.
But rather the fact that you
can declare you know something.
So you have an explicit
memory of your name.
Presumably you have an explicit memory
of the house or the apartment
that you grew up in.
You know something and
you know you know it.
And you can declare it.
So I can ask you, what was the color
of the first car that you owned?
Or what is the color of your
romantic partner's hair?
These sorts of things.
That's an explicit declarative memory.
But you also have explicit
procedural memories.
Now procedural memories,
as the name suggests,
involve action sequences.
The simplest one, it's
almost ridiculously simple,
is walking.
If I say, how is it that you walk
from one room to the other?
You'd probably say,
well, I go that direction
and then I turn left.
I say, no, no, no.
How is it exactly that you do it?
You say, well, I move my left foot,
then my right foot, then my left foot.
And you could describe that.
So it's an explicit procedural memory.
So much so that if you were going
to teach a young toddler how to walk,
you would probably say
okay, good, good, try.
Okay, then you know, probably
that's going to be pre-language
for the toddler.
But you're going to encourage them
to move one leg then the other.
And you're going to
encourage and reward them
for moving one leg then the other.
Because you have an explicit
procedural memory of how to walk.
Okay, almost ridiculously simple.
Maybe even truly ridiculously simple,
but nonetheless, when you think about it
in the context of neural
circuits and neural firing,
pretty amazing.
Even more amazing is the fact that all
explicit memories, both declarative
and procedural explicit memories
can be moved from explicit to implicit.
What do I mean by that?
Well, in the example of walking
you might have chuckled a little bit
or kind of shook your head and said,
this is a ridiculous thing to ask.
How do I walk from one room to the next?
I just walk.
I just do it.
Ah, well, what is just do it?
What it is, is that you have
an implicit understanding.
Meaning your nervous
system knows how to walk
without you actually having to think about
what you know about how to walk.
You just get up out of your chair
or you get up out of bed and you walk.
In the brain you have a structure.
In fact, you have one on
each side of your brain.
It's called the hippocampus.
The hippocampus literally means seahorse.
Anatomists like to name
brain structures after things
that they think those
brain structures resemble.
When I look at the hippocampus,
frankly, it doesn't look like a seahorse.
Which either reflects
my lack of understanding
of what a seahorse really
looks like, a visual deficit,
or I think it's fair to say
that those anatomists
were using a little bit
of creative elaboration
when thinking about
what the hippocampus looks like.
Nonetheless, it is a curved structure.
It has many layers.
It's been described by my
colleague Robert Sapolsky
and by others as looking
more like a jelly roll
or a cinnamon roll, is
what it looks like to me.
And if you were to take one cinnamon roll,
chop it down the middle.
So now you've got two half cinnamon rolls
and rather than put them back together
in the configuration they were before,
you just slide one down so that you've got
essentially two C's.
Two C-shaped halves of this cinnamon roll
and you push them together, right,
slightly off set from one another.
Well, that's what the
hippocampus looks like to me.
And I think that's a
far better description
of its actual physical structure.
But I guess if you were to
use that physical structure
as the name, well then
you'd have to open up
a brain atlas and it would be called
two half-C cinnamon rolls
stuffed halfway together.
So that's not very good.
So I guess, seahorse will work.
Hippocampus is the name of this structure
and it is the site in your brain,
and again, you have one on
each side of your brain,
in which explicit declarative
memories are formed.
It is not where those memories
are stored and maintained.
It is where they are
established in the first place.
In contrast, implicit memories,
the subconscious memories,
are formed and stored
elsewhere in the brain.
Mainly by areas like the cerebellum,
but also the neocortex,
the kind of outer shell of your brain.
The cerebellum literally means mini-brain.
And it does in fact
look like a mini-brain.
And is in the back of the brain.
And the neocortex is the
outer part of the brain
that covers all the other stuff.
So, the hippocampus is vitally important
for establishing these
new, declarative memories
of what you know and
what you know how to do.
Now, in order to really
understand the role
of the hippocampus in
memory, in particular
explicit declarative, and
explicit procedural memory
and to really understand
how that's distinct
from implicit declarative and
implicit procedural memories
we have to look to a clinical case.
And the clinical case
that I'm referring to
is a patient who went by the name HM.
Patient's go by their initials in order
to maintain confidentiality
of their real identity.
HM had what's called intractable epilepsy.
So he would have these really dramatic,
so-called grand mal
seizures, or drop seizures.
For those of you that know
somebody with epilepsy,
or that have epilepsy, you
might be familiar with this.
You can have petite mal seizures,
which are minor seizures.
You can have tonic clonic seizures,
which are sometimes not even detectable.
You can have absent seizures where people
will just stop, it's
almost as if their brain
kind of goes on pause and
they'll just stop there.
It was reported actually that
Einstein had absent seizures.
Although I don't know that's ever
really been confirmed neurologically.
Grand mal seizures are extremely severe
and that's what HM had.
So he could just be going about his day
and maybe even cooking, or
doing something, driving,
operating any kind of machinery,
and then all of a sudden
he would just have
a drop seizure.
So he would just physically drop
and go into a grand mal seizure.
So convulsing of the whole body,
loss of consciousness, etc.
Or he would feel it coming on.
Often times people with epilepsy
can feel the epileptic seizure coming on.
Kind of like a wave from
the back of the brain.
And sometimes they can get
to a safe circumstance, but not always.
And so the frequency and the
intensity of his seizures
were so robust that the neurosurgeons
and neurologists decided
that they needed to locate
the origin, what they call the foci
of those seizures, and
remove that brain tissue.
Because the way seizures work
is they spread out from that focus,
or that foci of brain tissue.
And unfortunately for HM,
the focus of his seizures
was the hippocampus.
So after a lot of deliberation,
a neurosurgeon, in fact
one of the most famous
neurosurgeons in the world at that time,
made what are called electrolytic lesions,
actually burned out the
hippocampus in the brain of HM.
And as a consequence, he
lost all explicit memory.
Now the consequence of this
was that he couldn't exist in normal,
everyday life, like most people.
So he had to live mostly, not entirely,
but mostly in a kind of hospital setting.
And I've talked to
several people, who have
I should say, who met HM directly,
because he's no longer alive.
But an interaction with him
might look like the following.
He would walk up to you just fine.
You wouldn't know that he
had any kind of brain damage.
He could walk fine, he could speak fine.
And you'd say, hi, I'm Andrew.
And he'd say, hi, I'm whatever
his name happened to be.
He wouldn't say HM, but he'd
probably say his real name.
And then perhaps someone new
would walk into the room.
He might turn around, look at that person,
as any of us might do.
Then turn around back to me
and say, hi, what's your name?
And if I were to say, well,
I just told you my name.
And you just told me your
name, do you remember that?
And he'd say, I'm sorry, I
don't remember any of that.
What's your name?
So you'd go through this
over and over again.
So a complete lack of
explicit declarative memory.
Now he did have some memory for
previous events in his life
that dated way back, okay.
Again, hinting at the idea that memories
are not necessarily
stored in the hippocampus,
they're just formed in the hippocampus.
So once they've moved
out of the hippocampus
to other brain areas, he could
still keep those memories.
They're in a different
database, if you will.
They're in a different pattern of firing
of other neural circuits.
But he couldn't form new memories.
Now there's some very important
and interesting twists on what HM could
and could not do in terms
of learning and memory
that teach us a lot about the brain.
In fact, I think most
neuroscientists would agree
that this unfortunate
case of HM's epilepsy
and the subsequent neuro
surgery that he had
taught us much of what we know,
or at least think about,
in terms of human learning and memory.
For instance, as I mentioned before,
he still had implicit knowledge.
He knew how to walk.
He knew how to do certain things like
make a cup of coffee.
He knew the names of people
that he had met much earlier
in his life, and so on.
And yet he couldn't form new memories.
Now, in violation to that last statement,
there were some elements
of HM's emotionality
that suggests that there was some sort
of residual capacity to
learn new information
but it wasn't what we normally think of
as explicit declarative
or procedural memory.
For instance, it's been reported
or it's been said, I should say,
because I don't know that the studies
were ever done with intense
physiological measurements,
that if you were to tell HM a joke,
and he thought it was funny,
he would laugh really hard.
He liked jokes, so you'd say hey, HM,
I want to tell you a joke.
You tell him a joke and
he'd laugh really hard.
Then you could leave the room, come back,
and tell him the same joke again.
Now keep in mind, he did not remember
that you told him the joke previously.
And the second time he would
laugh a little bit less.
And then you'd leave the
room, come back again.
Say hi, I'm Andrew.
And he'd say, oh, nice to meet you.
Because as you know, as you recall,
because you can recall things.
But he couldn't recall things.
He didn't know that he just met you.
Or at least he couldn't remember it.
You tell him the joke a
third time, or a fourth time,
and with each subsequent
telling of the joke
he found it a little less funny.
Just as, keep this in mind, folks,
if you tell a joke and
you get a big laugh,
don't tell it again.
At least not immediately.
Not to the same person or the same crowd
because the second time
it's a little less funny
and the third time it's
a little less funny.
And that actually has to
do with a whole element
of dopamine and it's
relationship to surprise.
And that's the topic of a future podcast
where we talk all about humor
and novelty in the brain.
But the point being that
certain forms of memory
seem to exist in a kind
of phantom like way
within HM's brain.
What do I mean by that?
Well, this underscores that he had
an implicit memory of having
heard the joke before.
And it suggests that humor, or
at least what we find funny,
is somehow more related to procedures.
Similar to walking or a motor ability
than it is to this precise
content of that joke.
All right, that's a little
bit of an abstract concept,
but the point is that HM lacked
explicit declarative memory.
He couldn't tell you
what he had just heard.
He could not learn new information.
And he couldn't tell
you how to do something
unless he had learned
how to do that something
many years prior.
Now, there have been a lot
of other patients besides HM
that have had brain
lesions due to epilepsy,
or I should say due to
surgeries to treat epilepsy,
due to strokes, due to
sadly gunshot wounds
and other forms of what
we call infarcts, infarct.
I-N-F-A-R-C-T, infarct is the word we use
to describe damage to a
particular brain region.
And many different patients
with many different patterns
of infarct have taught
us a lot about how memory
and other aspects of the brain work.
HM really teaches us that what we know
and what we are able to
do is the consequence
of things that we are aware of
and learnings that have been passed off
into subconscious knowledge,
that our body knows.
Our brain knows, but we don't know exactly
how we know that thing.
And I tell you the
story about HM's ability
to understand a joke, but
that with repeated telling
of the joke it has less and less and less
of an impact in creating
a sense of laughter,
of humor in HM.
Not as just an anecdote
to flesh out his story,
but because emotion itself turns out
to be the way in which
we can enhance memories
even if those are memories for things
that are not funny, are not intensely sad,
are not immensely happy or don't evoke
a really strong emotional response,
or even any emotional response.
And the reason for that is that emotions,
just like perception, just like sensation,
are the consequence of
particular neuro chemicals
being present in our brain and body.
And as I'm going to tell you next,
there are particular neuro chemicals
that you can leverage in order to learn
specific information
faster and to remember it
for a much longer period of time,
maybe even forever.
And you can do that by leveraging
the relationship in your nervous system
between your brain and your body.
And your body back to your brain.
So let's talk about tools
for enhancing memory.
Now there's one tool that
it's absolutely clear works.
And it's always worked, it works now,
and it will work forever.
And that's repetition.
The more often that you perform something
or that you recite something,
the more likely you are to
remember it in the future.
And while that might seem obvious,
it's worth thinking about what's happening
when you repeat something.
But when I say what's happening,
I mean at the neural level.
What's happening is
that you're encouraging
the firing of particular chains of neurons
that reside in a
particular circuit, right.
So a particular sequence
of neurons playing
neuron A, B, C, D played
in that particular sequence
over and over and over again.
And with more repetitions,
you get more strengthening
of those nerve connections.
Now, repetition works but
the problem for most people
is they either don't have the patience,
they don't have the time,
and sometimes they literally
don't have the time
because they've got a deadline
on something that they're
trying to remember and learn.
Or they simply would like to be able
to remember things better in general
and remember them more quickly.
This process of accelerating
repetition based learning
so that your learning curve doesn't go
from having to perform
something 1,000 times
and then gradually over time
it's 1,000, 750 times a day,
500 times a day, 300 times a day,
and down to no repetitions, right?
You can just perform
that thing the first time
and every time.
Well, there is a way to shift that curve
so that you can essentially
establish stronger connections
between the neurons that are involved
in generating that memory
or behavior more quickly.
How do you do that?
Well, in order to answer that we have
to look at the beautiful
work of James McGaugh
and Larry Cahill.
James McGaugh and Larry Cahill did
a number experiments over
several decades really
based on a lot of animal literature,
but mainly focused on humans
that really established what's required
to get better at remembering things
and to do so very quickly.
I want to talk about one
experiment that they did
that was particularly important.
And we will provide a link to this paper,
it's some years old now,
but the results still hold up.
In fact, the results established
an entire field of memory and
neuroscience and psychology.
What they did is they had human subjects
come into the laboratory and to read
a short paragraph of about 12 sentences.
And the key thing is
that some subjects read
a paragraph that was pretty mundane.
The content, the information
within the paragraph
was all related to the content
of the previous sentence.
So it was a cogent paragraph.
Right, it just wasn't a
meaningless scramble of words.
But it described a kind of
mundane set of circumstances.
Maybe it would be a story about someone
who walked into a room,
sat down at a desk,
wrote for a little bit, then got up
and had lunch.
You know, just kind of
mundane information.
Not very interesting.
Another group of subjects read also
a 12 sentence paragraph.
But that paragraph included a subset
of sentences that had a lot of
emotionally intense language.
Or that had language that could evoke
an emotionally intense response
in the person reading it.
So it might have talked
about a car accident
or a very intense surgery.
But it also could be positive stuff.
Things like a birthday party,
or a celebration of some other kind.
Or a big sports win.
So in other words, you have
two conditions of this study.
People either read a boring paragraph,
or they read a really
emotionally laden paragraph.
And again, the emotions could either be
positive or negative emotions.
Subjects left the laboratory
and sometime later
they were called back to the laboratory
and I should say, at no
point in the experiment
did they know they were
part of a memory experiment.
Okay, they don't even know why
they were reading this paragraph.
They came in either for
class credit or to get paid.
That's typically how these things are done
on college campuses or elsewhere.
They come back into the lab
and they would get a pop quiz.
They would be asked to recall the content
of the paragraph that
they had read previously.
Now as is probably expected,
perhaps even obvious to you,
the subjects that read the
emotionally intense paragraph
remembered far more of the
content of that paragraph
and were far more accurate
in their remembering of that information.
Now, that particular
finding wasn't very novel.
Many people had previously described
how emotionally intense events
are better remembered than
non-emotionally intense events.
In fact, way back in the 1600s
Francis Bacon, who's largely credited
with developing the scientific method,
said, quote, memory is
assisted by anything
that makes an impression
on a powerful passion.
Inspiring fear, for example,
or wonder, shame, or joy.
Francis Bacon said that in 1620.
So Jim McGaugh and Larry Cahill
were certainly not the first
to demonstrate or to conceive of the idea
that emotionally laden experiences
are more easily remembered
than other experiences.
However, what they did next
was immensely important for
our understanding of memory
and for our building of tools
to enhance learning and memory.
What they did was they evaluated
the capacity for stress and for particular
neuro chemicals associated with stress
to improve our ability
to learn information.
Not just information that is emotional,
but information of all kinds.
So I'm going to describe
some experiments done
in animal models just very briefly,
and then experiments
done on humans subjects.
Because McGaugh worked mainly on animals,
also human subjects.
Larry Cahill, almost
exclusively on human subjects.
If you take a rat or a mouse
and put it in an arena
where at one location
the animal receives an electrical shock
and then you come back the next day,
you remove the shock evoking device
and you let the animal
move around that arena,
that animal will, quite understandably,
avoid the location where it was shocked.
So called conditioned place aversion.
That affect of avoiding
that particular location
occurs in one trial.
That's a good example
of one trial learning.
So somehow the animal knows
that it was shocked at that location,
it remembers that.
It is a hippocampal dependent learning.
So animals that lack a hippocampus
or who have their
hippocampus pharmacologically
or otherwise incapacitated, will not learn
that new bit of information.
But for animals that do, they remember it
after the first time and every time.
Unless, you are to block the release
of certain chemicals in the brain and body
and the chemicals I'm
referring to are epinephrine,
adrenaline, and to some
extent the corticosterones.
Things like cortisol.
Now we know that the effect
of getting one trial learning
somehow involves epinephrine,
at least in this particular
experimental scenario.
Because if researchers do
the exact same experiment,
and they have done the
exact same experiment,
but they introduce a
pharmacological blocker
of epinephrine, so that
epinephrine is released
in response to the shock,
but it cannot actually
bind to its receptors
and have all its biological effects,
well then the animal is perfectly happy
to tread back into the area
where it received the shock.
It's almost as if it didn't know,
or we have to assume, it didn't remember
that it received the
shock at that location.
So it all seems pretty
obvious when you hear it.
Something bad happens in a location,
you don't go back to that location.
So that's condition place avoidance.
But it turns out that the
opposite is also true.
Meaning for something called
condition place preference
you can take an animal,
put it into an arena,
feed it or reward it
some how at one location
in that arena.
So you can give a hungry rat or mouse food
at one particular location,
take the animal out,
come back the next day.
No food is introduced, but it will go back
to the location where
it received the food.
Or you can do any variant of this.
You can make the arena a little bit chilly
and provide warmth at that location.
Or you can take a male animal.
And it turns out male rats and mice
will mate at any point.
Or a female animal
that's at the particular
so called receptive
phase of her mating cycle
and give them an opportunity to mate
at a give location, they'll
go back to that location
and wait away.
This is perhaps why people go back
to the same bar, or the seat at the bar,
or the same restaurant and wait
because of the one time they, you know,
things worked out for them.
Whatever the context was.
Condition place preference.
Condition place preference as
with condition place avoidance
depends on the release
of adrenaline, right.
It's not just about stress.
It's about a heightened emotional state
in the brain and body.
Okay, this is really important.
It's not just about stress.
You can get one trial learning
for positive events,
condition place preference.
And you can get one trial
learning for negative events.
Here I say positive and negative,
I'm putting what's called valence on it.
Making a value judgment about whether not
the animal liked it or didn't like it.
And we have to presume
what the animal liked
or didn't like and how it felt.
But this turns out all to
be true for humans as well.
We know that because McGaugh and Cahill
did experiments where they gave people
a boring paragraph to read
and only a boring paragraph to read.
But one group of subjects was asked
to read the paragraph and
then to place their arm
into very, very cold water.
In fact, it was ice water.
We know that placing
one's arm into ice water,
especially if it's up to
the shoulder or near to it,
evokes the release of
adrenaline in the body.
It's not an enormous release,
but it's a significant increase.
And yes, they measured adrenaline release.
In some cases they also
measured for things like
cortisol, etc.
And what they found is that if one evokes
the release of adrenaline through
this arm into ice water approach,
the information that they read previously,
just a few minutes before,
was remembered, it was retained as well
as emotionally intense information.
But keep in mind the
information that they read
was not interesting at all.
Or at least, it wasn't emotionally laden.
This had to be the effect
of adrenaline released
into the brain and body, because
if they blocked the release
or the function of adrenaline in the brain
and or body, they could block this effect.
Now the biology of
epinephrine and cortisol
are a little bit complex,
but there's some nuance there
that's actually interesting
and important to us.
First of all, adrenaline is released
in the body and in the brain.
It's released in the
body from the adrenals.
Remember, epinephrine and
adrenaline are the same thing.
Cortisol is also released
from the adrenal glands.
These two little glands
that ride atop our kidneys.
But it can't cross into the brain.
It only has what we
call peripheral effects.
Quickening of the heart rate, right?
Changes the patterns of blood flow.
Changes our patterns of breathing.
In general, makes our breathing
more shallow and faster.
In general makes our heart
beat more quickly, etc.
Within our brain we
have a little brain area
called locus coeruleus, which
is in the back of the brain.
Which has the opportunity to sprinkler
the rest of the brain with
the neuromodulator
epinephrine, adrenaline,
as well as norepinephrine,
a related neuromodulator.
And to essentially wake up or
create a state of alertness
throughout the brain.
So it's a very general effect.
The reason we have two sites of release
is because these neuro
chemicals do not cross
the blood-brain barrier.
And so waking up the body with adrenaline
and waking up the brain are two separate,
so-called parallel phenomena.
Cortisol can cross the blood-brain barrier
because it's lipophilic.
Meaning it can move through fatty tissue.
And we'll get into the biology of that
in another episode.
But cortisol in general is released
and has much longer term effects.
And as I just told you, can permeate
throughout the brain and body.
Adrenaline has more local effects.
Or at least is segregated
between the brain and the body.
This will turn out to be important later.
The important thing to keep in mind
is that it is the emotionality evoked
by an experience, or to be more precise,
it is the emotional state that you are in
after you experience something
that dictates whether
or not you will learn it
quickly or not.
This is absolutely important
in terms of thinking about tools
to improve your memory.
And no, I am not going to suggest
that every time you
want to learn something
you plunge your arm into ice water.
Why won't I suggest that?
Well, it will induce the
release of adrenaline,
but there are better ways to
get that adrenaline release.
Before I explain exactly
what those tools are,
I want to tamp down on the biology
of how all this works.
Because in that understanding
you will have access
to the best possible tools
to improve your memory.
First of all, McGaugh and Cahill
were excellent experimentalists.
They did not just establish that you could
quicken the formation of a memory
by accessing material that
was very emotionally laden
or creating an emotional,
high adrenaline state
after interacting with some thing.
Some word, some person, some information.
They also tested whether
or not that whole effect
could be blocked by
blocking the emotional state
or by blocking adrenaline.
So what they did is they
had people read paragraphs
that either had a lot of emotional content
or they had people read paragraphs
that were pretty boring, but then had them
put their arm into ice water.
And I should say they
did other experiments too
to increase adrenaline.
There were even some shock experiments
that were done by other groups.
Any number of things to evoke
the release of adrenaline.
Even people taking drugs
that increase adrenaline.
But then they also did what are
called blocking experiments.
They did experiments where they had people
get into a highly emotional state
from reading highly emotional material,
or they got people to get
into a highly emotional
neuro chemical state by
reading boring material
and then taking a drug
to increase adrenaline,
or an ice bath, or a shock.
And then they also administered
a drug called a beta blocker
to block the affect of adrenaline
and related chemicals
in the brain and body.
And what they found is that even
if people were exposed to
something really emotional
or had a lot of adrenaline in their system
because they received a drug to increase
the amount of adrenaline.
Two manipulations that
normally would increase memory,
keep that in mind.
If they gave them a beta blocker,
which reduced the response
to that adrenaline, right?
So no quickening of the heart rate.
No quickening of the breathing.
No increase in the
activity of locus coeruleus
and these kind of wake up
signals to the rest of the brain.
Well then, the material wasn't
remembered better at all.
What this tells us is that, yes,
Francis Bacon was right.
McGaugh and Cahill were right.
Hundreds, if not
thousands of philosophers,
and psychologists, and
neuroscientists were right.
In stating and in thinking that
high emotional states
help you learn things.
But what McGaugh and Cahill really showed,
and what's most important to know,
is that it is the presence
of high adrenaline,
high amounts of
norepinephrine and epinephrine
and perhaps cortisol as
well, as you'll soon see,
that allows a memory to
be stamped down quickly.
It is not the emotion.
It is the neuro chemical
state that you go into
as a consequence of the emotion.
And it's very important to understand
that while those two things are related,
they are not one and the same thing.
Because what that means
is that were you to evoke
the release of epinephrine,
norepinephrine, and cortisol
or even just one or two of those chemicals
after experiencing something,
you are stamping down the experience
that you just previously had.
Now this is fundamentally important
and far and away different than the idea
that we remember things because
they're important to us,
or because they evoke emotion.
That's true, but the real reason,
the neuro chemical reason,
the mechanism behind all that
is these neuro chemicals have the ability
to strengthen neural connections
by making them active just once.
There's something truly magic about
that neuro chemical cocktail that removes
the need for repetition.
Okay, so let's apply this knowledge.
Let's establish a scientifically
grounded set of tools.
Meaning tools that take into account
the identity of the neuro chemicals
that are important for enhancing learning
and the timing of the
release of those chemicals
in order to enhance learning.
When I first learned about the results
of McGaugh and Cahill,
I was just blown away.
I was also pretty upset,
but not with them,
I was upset with myself.
Because I realized that the way that I had
been approaching learning
and memory was not optimal.
In fact, it was probably
in the opposite direction
to the enhanced protocol
for learning and memory
that I'm going to teach you today.
My typical mode of
trying to learn something
while I was in college, or
while I was in graduate school,
or as a junior professor,
or a tenured professor
was to sit down to
whatever it is I was going
to try and learn, and
perhaps even memorize.
Or if it was a physical
skill, move to whatever
environment I was going to
learn that physical skill in,
and prior to that, to make sure that I was
hydrated, because that's important to me.
And certainly can
contribute to your brain's
ability to function and your
body's ability to function.
And general patterns of alertness.
But also, to caffeinate.
I would have a nice, strong
cup of coffee or espresso.
I would have a nice
strong cup of yerba mate.
And I still drink coffee or
yerba mate very regularly.
I drink them in moderation, I think.
Certainly for me.
But typically I would drink those things
before I would engage
in any kind of attempt
to learn or memorize.
Or to acquire a new skill.
Now caffeine in the form
of coffee or yerba mate
or any other form of caffeine does create
a sense of alertness in our brain and body
and it does that through
two major mechanisms.
The first mechanism is by
blocking the effects of adenosine.
Adenosine is a molecule that builds up
in the brain and body the
longer that we are awake.
And it's largely what's responsible
for our feelings of sleepiness and fatigue
when we've been awake
for a very long time.
Caffeine essentially acts to block
the effects of adenosine.
It's a competing agonist,
not to get technical,
but it binds to the receptor for adenosine
for some period of time
and prevents adenosine
from having its normal pattern of action.
And thereby reduces our
feelings of fatigue.
But it also increases state of alertness.
So while it's reducing fatigue,
it's also pushing on
neuro chemical systems
in order to directly
increase our alertness.
And it does that in
large part by increasing
the transmission of
epinephrine, adrenaline,
in the brain and body.
It also has this interesting
effect of up regulating
the number and or efficiency,
or we say the efficacy,
of dopamine receptors.
Such that when dopamine is present,
and is a molecule that
increases motivation,
and craving, and pursuit, that dopamine
can have a more potent effect
than it would otherwise.
So caffeine really hits
these three systems.
It hits other systems too,
but it mainly reduces fatigue
by reducing adenosine, increases alertness
by increasing epinephrine release,
or adrenaline release I should say,
both from the adrenals in your body
and form locus coeruleus
from within the brain.
And it can, in parallel
to all that, increase
the action or the efficacy
of the action of dopamine.
So my typical way of
approaching learning and memory
would be to drink some caffeine
and then focus really hard
on whatever it is that
I'm trying to learn.
Try and eliminate distractions
and then hope, hope, hope.
Or try, try, try to
remember that information
as best as I could.
And frankly, I felt like it
was working pretty well for me.
And typically, if I leveraged other forms
of pharmacology in order to
enhance learning and memory,
things like Alpha GPC,
or phosphatidyl serine,
I would do that by taking those things
before I sat down to learn
a particular set of information.
Or before I went off to learn
a particular physical skill.
Now, for those of you out
there listening to this
you're probably thinking, well, okay.
The results of McGaugh and Cahill pointed
to the fact that having
adrenaline released after
learning something enhanced
learning of that thing.
But a lot of these things like caffeine,
or Alpha GPC can increase
epinephrine and adrenaline
or dopamine or other molecules
in the brain and body
that can enhance memory
for a long period of time.
So it makes sense to take it first,
or even during learning,
and then allow that increase to occur.
And the increase will occur over
a long period of time and will
enhance learning and memory.
And while that is partially true,
it is not entirely true.
And it turns out it's not optimal.
Work that was done by
the McGaugh laboratory,
and in other laboratories evaluated
the precise temporal relationship
between neuro chemical
activation of these pathways
and learning and memory.
What they did is they had
animals and or people,
depending on the experiment, take a drug.
It could be caffeine.
It could be in pill form.
Something that would increase adrenaline
or related molecules that create
this state of alertness that
are related to emotionality.
And they had them do it
either an hour before,
30 minutes before, 10 minutes before,
or five minutes before learning,
or during the about of learning, right?
The reading of the
information or the performing
of the skill that one is trying to learn.
Or five minutes, 10 minutes, 15 minutes,
30 minutes, etc. afterwards.
So they looked very
precisely at when exactly
is best to evoke this adrenaline release.
And it turns out that the best time window
to evoke the release of these chemicals,
if the goal is to enhance
learning and memory
of the material is
either immediately after
or just a few minutes,
five, 10, maybe 15 minutes
after you're repeating that information.
You're trying to learn that information.
Again, this could be cognitive information
or this could be a physical skill.
Now this really spits in the face
of the way that most of us
approach learning and memory.
Most of us, if we use
stimulants like caffeine
or Alpha GPC, we're taking those before
or during an attempt to
learn, not afterwards.
These results point to the fact that
it is after the learning and memory
that you really want to
get that big increase
in epinephrine and the related molecules
that will tamp down memory.
So what this means is that
if you are currently using
caffeine or other compounds,
and we'll talk about what those are
and safety issues and
so forth in a moment.
If you're using those compounds in order
to enhance learning and memory
by taking them before or
during a learning episode,
well then I encourage you to try
and take them either late
in the learning episode
or immediately after the learning episode.
Now given everything I've
told you up until now
why would I say late
in the learning episode
or immediately after?
Well, when you ingest
something by drinking it
or you take it in capsule form,
there's a period of time before that gets
absorbed into the body.
And different substances,
such as caffeine, Alpha GPC, etc
are absorbed from the gut
and into the blood stream
and reach the brain and
trigger these affects
in the brain and body at different rates.
So it's not instantaneous.
Some have effects within minutes,
others within tens of minutes and so on.
It's really going to depend
on the pharmacology of those things
and it's also going to depend
on whether or not you
have food in your gut,
what else you happen to have circulating
in your blood stream, etc.
But at a very basic level
we can confidently say
that there are not one, not dozens,
but as I mentioned before,
hundreds of studies in
animals and in humans
that point to the fact that triggering
the increase of adrenaline
late in learning
or immediately after learning
is going to be most beneficial
if your goal is to retain that information
for some period of time.
And to reduce the number of repetitions
required in order to
learn that information.
Now, I want to acknowledge that
on previous episodes of this podcast
and in appearing on other podcasts,
I've talked a lot about things
like non-sleep deep rest,
and naps, and sleep as vital
to the learning process.
And I want to emphasize
that none of that information has changed.
I don't look at any of that
information differently
as the consequence of what
I'm talking about today.
It is still true that the strengthening
of connections in the brain,
the literal neural plasticity,
the changing of the circuits occurs
during deep sleep and non-sleep deep rest.
And it is also true,
and I've mentioned these results earlier
that two papers were
published in Cell Reports,
Cell Press journal, excellent journal
over the last few years showing that
brief naps of about 20 up to 90 minutes
in some period of time
after an attempt to learn
can enhance the rate
of learning and memory.
However, those bouts of sleep,
the deep sleep that night, I should say,
or those brief naps,
or even the so-called NSDR as we call it,
non-sleep deep rest that was used
to enhance the learning and memory
of particular pieces of information.
Either cognitive or physical
information or both.
That still can be performed,
but it can be performed some hours later,
even an hour later.
It can be performed two hours
later or four hours later.
Remember, it's in these
naps and in deep sleep
that the actual reconfiguration
of the neural circuits occurs,
the strengthening of those
neural circuits occurs.
It is not the case that you need to finish
a about of learning and drop
immediately into a nap or sleep.
Some people might do that,
but if you're really trying to optimize
and enhance and improve your memory,
the data from McGaugh and Cahill
and many other laboratories
that stemmed out
from their initial work really point
to the fact that the
ideal protocol would be
focus on the thing you're
trying to learn very intensely.
There are also some other
things like error rates, etc.
Please see our episodes on learning.
We have a newsletter
on how to learn better.
You can access that at HubermanLab.com.
It's a zero cost newsletter.
You can grab that PDF.
It lists out the things to
do during the learning about.
Still try and get excellent sleep.
Again, fundamentally
important for mental health,
physical health, and performance.
And we can now extend from performance
to saying including learning and memory.
Nap if it doesn't interrupt
your nighttime sleep.
Naps of anywhere from 10 to 90 minutes.
Or non-sleep deep rest protocols
will enhance learning and memory,
but we can now add to that,
that spiking adrenaline
provided it can be done in a safe way,
is going to reduce the
number of repetitions
required to learn.
And that should be done
at the very tail end
or immediately after a learning about.
Which is compatible with all
the other protocols that I mentioned.
And the reason I'm revisiting this stuff
about sleep and non-sleep deep rest
is I think that some
people got the impression
that they need to do that
immediately after learning
and today I'm saying to the contrary.
Immediately after learning
you need to go into
a heightened state of
emotionality and alertness.
Now it's vitally important to point out
that you do not need pharmacology.
You don't need caffeine.
You don't need Alpha GPC.
You don't need any pharmacologic substance
to spike adrenaline
unless that's something
that you already are doing.
Or that you can do safely.
Or that you know you can do safely.
And I always say, and I'll say it again,
I'm not a physician so I'm
not prescribing anything.
I'm a professor, so I profess things.
You need to what's safe for you.
So if you're somebody who's
not used to drinking caffeine
and you suddenly drink
four espresso after trying
to learn something, you are going to have
a severe increase in alertness
and probably even anxiety.
If you're panic attack prone,
please don't start taking stimulants
in order to learn things better.
Please be safe.
I don't just say that to protect me,
I say that to protect you.
And I should mention that if you're
not accustomed to taking something,
you always want to first check
with your doctor, of course,
but also move into that gradually, right?
Start with the lowest effective dose.
The minimal effective dose.
And sometimes the minimal effective dose
is zero milligrams, it's nothing.
Why do I say that?
Well, we already talked
about results where
they put people's arms into an ice bath
in order to evoke adrenaline release.
You are welcome to do that if you want.
In fact, that's a pretty
low cost, zero pharmacology.
At least exogenous pharmacology way
to approach this whole thing.
That's a way of evoking
your own natural epinephrine
that turns out also dopamine release.
You could take a cold shower.
You could do an ice bath or get into
a cold circulating bath.
We've done several episodes
on the utility of cold for
health and performance.
You can find those episodes
at HubermanLab.com.
Also the episode with
my colleague at Stanford
from the biology department,
Dr. Craig Heller.
Lots of protocols, in
particular in the episode
on cold for health and performance.
That describe how best to use
the cold shower or the ice bath
or the circulating cold bath
in order to evoke epinephrine
and dopamine release.
The point is that the time in which
you would want to do those protocols
is after, ideally immediately
after your learning about.
Meaning when you're sitting down to learn
new information or after trying
to learn some new physical skill.
Now whether or not that's compatible
with the other reasons you're doing
deliberate cold exposure,
and whether or not that's compatible
with the other things you're doing,
that depends on the
contour of your lifestyle,
your training, your academic goals,
your learning goals, etc.
But if your specific purpose is to enhance
learning and memory, you want
to spike adrenaline afterwards.
And so what I'm telling
you is you can do that
with caffeine.
You can do that with Alpha GPC.
You can do that with a combination
of caffeine and Alpha GPC.
If you can do that safely.
Some of you I know are using
other forms of pharmacology.
I did a long episode all about ADHD.
I have to just really declare
my stance very clearly
that I am not a fan, I am actually opposed
to people using prescription drugs
who are not prescribed those drugs
in order to enhance alertness.
I think there's a big addictive potential.
There also is a potential to really
disrupt one's own pharmacology around
the dopaminergic system.
However, some of you I know are prescribed
things like ritalin,
Adderall and modafinil
and things of that sort in order
to increase alertness and focus.
So for those of you that are prescribed
those things from a board
certified physician,
you're going to have to decide
if you're going to take
them before trying to learn
or after trying to learn.
You also have to take into consideration
that some of those drugs
are very long acting.
Some are shorter acting.
And time that according
to what you're trying to learn and when.
So that's pharmacology.
But as I mentioned, there
are the behavioral protocols.
You can use cold and cold
is an excellent stimulus
because first of all, it
doesn't involve pharmacology.
Second of all, you can generally access it
at low to zero cost, especially
the cold shower approach.
And third, you can titrate it.
You can start with warmer water.
You can make it very, very
cold if that's your thing
and you're able to tolerate that safely.
You can make it moderately cold.
How cold should it be in order
to invoke adrenaline release?
Well, it should be uncomfortably cold
but cold enough that you feel like
you really want to get out,
but can stay in safely.
That's going to evoke adrenaline release.
If it quickens your breathing,
if it makes you go wide eyed.
That's increasing adrenaline release.
In fact, those effects of going wide eyed
and quickening of the breathing
and the challenges in thinking clearly,
those are the direct effects of adrenaline
on your brain and body.
And of course, there are other ways
to increase adrenaline.
You could go out for a hard run.
You could do any number of things
that would increase
adrenaline in your body.
Which things you choose is up to you,
but from a very clear, solid grounding
in research data, we can confidently say
that spiking adrenaline after interacting
with some material, physical
or cognitive material
that you're trying to learn,
is going to be the best time
to spike that adrenaline.
Now I realize I'm being
a bit redundant today
or perhaps a lot redundant.
In repeating over and over that
the increase in epinephrine should occur
either very late in an
attempt to learn something
or immediately after an
attempt to learn something.
I also want to emphasize
the general contour
of pharmacologic effects
and of behavioral tools
to create adrenaline.
What do I mean by that sentence?
What I mean is that McGaugh and colleagues
explored a huge number
of different compounds and approaches.
Everything from the hand into the ice bath
to injecting adrenaline, to caffeine,
to drugs that block the affects
of adrenaline and caffeine.
Drugs like muscimol and picrotoxin.
Please don't take those.
These are drugs that reduce
or enhance the amount of adrenaline
and the overall takeaway is that anything
that increases adrenaline will increase
learning and memory and will reduce
the number of repetitions
required to learn something.
Regardless of whether
or not that something
has an emotional intensity or not.
Provided that spike in
adrenaline occurs late
in the learning or immediately after.
And anything that reduces
epinephrine and adrenaline
will impair learning.
And that's the key and
novel piece of information
that I'm adding now.
Which is if you're taking
beta blockers, for instance.
Or if you're trying to learn something
and it's not evoking much
of an emotional response,
and you're not using any pharmacology
or other methods to
enhance adrenaline release
after learning that thing, well,
you're not going to learn it very well.
In fact, McGaugh and Cahill
did beautiful experiments
in humans looking at how much adrenaline
is increased by varying
the emotional intensity
of different things that they were trying
to get people to learn.
Or by changing the dosage of epinephrine.
Or by changing the amount
of epinephrine blocker
that they injected.
Lots and lots of studies.
The key thing to take
away from those studies
is that for some people, adrenaline
was increased 600 to 700%.
So six to seven fold over baseline
in the amount of circulating
epinephrine or adrenaline.
And keep in mind, sometimes that increase
was due to the actual thing
they were trying to learn
being very emotional,
positive or negative emotion.
And sometimes it was
because they were using
a pharmacologic approach
or the ice bath approach.
I don't think they ever
used a cold shower approach,
but that would have been
a very effective one
we can be sure.
However, other people had
a zero to 10% increase.
So a very small increase in epinephrine.
What we can confidently say on the basis
of all those data is that
the more epinephrine release,
the better that people
remembered the material.
Over and over again this was shown.
Whether or not it was
for cognitive material,
so learning a language,
learning a passage of words,
learning mathematics.
Or whether or not it was
for physical learning.
I want to emphasize something
about physical learning
because I know a number
of you are probably
drinking a cup of coffee or having
a cup of yerba mate or
maybe even an energy drink
and taking some Alpha GPC or something
before physical exercise.
I'm not saying that's a bad thing to do
or you wouldn't want to do that.
But that's really to increase alertness.
It won't enhance learning,
at least not as well as
doing those things after
the physical exercise.
Now again, many of you, including myself,
exercise for the sake
of the physical benefits
of that exercise.
So cardiovascular, resistance training.
But we're not really focused
on learning and memory.
So, I emphasize this just so it's
immensely clear to everybody.
If you want to use those approaches
of increasing adrenaline prior to
or during physical training,
or cognitive work for
that matter, be my guest.
I think that's perfectly fine,
provided that's safe for you.
It's only by moving it to late
or after the learning that
you're really shifting
the role of that adrenaline increase
to enhancing memory specifically.
And as a cautionary note, don't think
that you can push this entire system
to the extreme over and over again,
or chronically, as we
say, and get away with it.
In other words, you're
not going to be able
to take a Alpha GPC and a double espresso
do your focus about of work,
cognitive or physical work,
and then spike adrenaline again afterwards
and remember that stuff
you did better, right.
I'm not encouraging you, in
fact I'm discouraging you
from chronically increasing adrenaline
both during and after
a given about of work
if the goal is to learn.
Why do I say that?
Well, work from McGaugh
and Cahill and others
has shown that it's
not the absolute amount
of adrenaline that you release
in your brain and body that
matters for enhancing memory.
It's the amount of adrenaline you release
relative to the amount of adrenaline
that was in your system just prior.
Particularly in the hour or two prior.
So again, it's the delta, as we say.
It's the difference.
So if you're going to
chronically increase adrenaline
you're not going to learn as well.
The real key is to have
adrenaline modestly low.
Perhaps even just as much as you need
in order to be able to focus on something,
pay attention to it, and
then spike it afterwards.
This is immensely important because
while much of what we're talking about
is actually a form of inducing
a neuro chemical acute stress.
Meaning a brief and rapid onset of stress.
Well, chronic stress,
the chronic elevation
of epinephrine and cortisol
is actually detrimental to learning.
And there's an entire
category of literature
mainly from the work of the great
and sadly the late Bruce McEwen
from the Rockefeller University.
And some of his scientific offspring
like the great Robert Sapolsky,
showing that chronic stress,
chronic elevation of epinephrine
actually inhibits learning and memory.
And also can inhibit
immune system function.
Whereas acute, right, sharp increases
in adrenaline and cortisol
actually can enhance learning
and indeed, can enhance the immune system.
So if you really want to
leverage this information,
you might consider getting
your brain and body
into a very calm and yet alert state.
So a high attentional state
that will allow you to focus on what it is
that you're trying to learn.
We know focus is vital
for encoding information
and for triggering neuroplasticity.
But remaining calm throughout that time
and then afterwards spiking adrenaline
and allowing adrenaline to
have these incredible effects
on reducing the number of repetitions
required to learn.
So if you're like me, you're
learning about this information
this beautiful work of
McGaugh and Cahill and others
and thinking, wow, I
should perhaps consider
spiking my adrenaline
in one form or another
at the tail end or immediately following
an attempt to learn something.
And yet, we are not the first
to have this conversation.
Nor were McGaugh and Cahill
or any other researchers
that I've discussed today
the first to start using this technique.
In fact, there is a beautiful review
that was published just
this year, May of 2022
in the journal Neuron, Cell Press Journal.
Excellent journal.
Called Mechanisms of Memory Under Stress.
And I just want to read to you
the first opening paragraph
of this review, which
is, as the name suggests,
all about memory and stress.
So here I'm reading, and I quote,
"In Medieval times communities threw"
"young children in the river when"
"they wanted them to
remember important events."
"They believed that throwing
a child in the water"
"after witnessing historic proceedings"
"would leave a life long memory"
"for the events in the child."
Believe it or not, this is true.
This is a practice that
somehow people arrived at.
I don't know if they were
aware of what adrenaline was.
Probably not.
But somehow in medieval times
it was understood that spiking adrenaline
or creating a robust emotional experience
after an experience that one
hoped a child would learn
would encourage the
child's nervous system,
they didn't even know
what a nervous system was,
but would encourage the brain and body
of that child to remember
those particular events.
Very counter intuitive if you ask me.
I would have thought that
the kid would remember
only being thrown into the river.
My guess is that they remember that,
but the idea here anyway,
is they also remember
the things that preceded
being thrown into the river.
So both interesting and amusing
and somewhat, I should say
thought stimulating, really.
That this is a practice
that has been going on
for many hundreds of years.
And we are not the first to start thinking
about using cold water as
an adrenaline stimulus.
Nor are we the first
to start thinking about
using cold water induced adrenaline
as a way to enhance learning and memory.
This has been happening
since medieval times.
So up until now I've been talking about
pretty broad contour of these experiments.
I've been talking about the
underlying pharmacology,
the role of epinephrine and so forth.
I haven't really talked a lot about
the underlying neural mechanisms.
So we're just going to
take a minute or two
and describe those for you
because they are informative.
We all have a brain structure
called the amygdala.
A lot of people think
it's associated with fear
but it's actually associated
with threat detection
and more generally, and I
should say more specifically,
with detecting what sorts of events
in the environment are
novel and are linked
to particular emotional states.
Both positive emotional states
and negative emotional states.
So the neurons in the
amygdala are exquisitely good
at figuring out, right, they
don't have their own mind
but at detecting correlations between
sensory events in the environment
that trigger the release of adrenaline
and what's going on in the brain.
And because the amygdala is so extensively
interconnected with
other areas of the brain.
It basically connects to everything
and everything connects back to it.
The amygdala is in a
position to strengthen
particular connections
in the brain very easily.
Provided certain conditions are met.
And those conditions are the ones
we've been talking about up until now.
Emotional saliency that
results in increases
in epinephrine and cortisol.
Or circulating epinephrine and cortisol
being much higher than it was 10 minutes
or 15 minutes before.
And the net effect of the amygdala
in this context is to
take whatever patterns
of neural activity preceded that increase
in adrenaline and corticosterone
and strengthen those
synapses that were involved
in that neural activity.
So the amygdala doesn't have knowledge.
It's not a thinking area.
It's a correlation detector.
And it's correlating neural chemical
states of the brain and body,
different patterns of electrical
activity in the brain.
This is important because
it really emphasizes
the fact that both negative
and positive emotional states
and the different but somewhat overlapping
chemical states that they create,
or the conditions, as we say the and gates
through which memory is laid down.
And gates will be familiar to those
of you who have done a bit
of a computer programming.
An and gate is simply a condition
in which you need one
thing and another to happen
in order for a third thing to happen.
So you need epinephrine
elevated and you need
robust activity in a
particular brain circuit
if in fact that brain circuit
is going to be strengthened.
It's not sufficient to have one
or the other, you need both.
Hence, the name and gate.
And the amygdala is very
good at establishing
these and gate contingencies.
It's also a very generic brain structure
in the sense that it doesn't really care
what sorts of sensory events are involved
provided they correlated in time
with that increase in
adrenal and corticosterone.
This has a wonderful side
and a kind of dark side.
The dark side is that PTSD and traumas
of various kinds often involve an increase
in adrenaline because whatever it was
that caused the PTSD was
indeed very stressful.
Caused these big increases
in these chemicals.
And because the amygdala is
rather general in its functions.
Right, it's not tuned or designed
in any kind of way to
be specifically active
in response to particular types
of sensory events, or perceptions.
Well, then what it means is that
we can start to become afraid
of entire city blocks where
one bad thing happened
in a particular room of
a particular building
in a city block.
We can become fearful of
anyplace that contains
a lot of people if
something bad happened to us
in a place that contained a lot of people.
The amygdala is not so much of a splitter,
as we say in science.
We talk about lumpers and splitters.
Lumpers are kind of generalizers,
if that's even a word.
And I think it is, someone will tell me
one way or the other.
And splitters are people
that are ultra precise
and specific and nuanced
about every little detail.
The amygdala is more of
a lumper than a splitter
when it comes to sensory events.
Other areas of the
brain only become active
under very, very specific conditions
and only those conditions.
And similarly, epinephrine
is just a molecule.
It's just a chemical that's circulating
in our brain and body.
There's no epinephrine specifically for
a cold shower that is
distinct from the epinephrine
associated with a bad event
which is distinct from the epinephrine
associated with a really exciting event
that makes you really alert.
Epinephrine is just a
molecule, it's generic.
So these systems have a lot of overlap
and that can explain, in large part,
why when good things happen
in particular locations
and in the company of particular people,
we often generalize to large categories
of people, places, and things.
And when negative things happen
in particular circumstances,
we often generalize about
people places and things
associated with that negative event.
So now I'd like to talk about other tools
that you can leverage that have been shown
in quality, peer-reviewed studies
to enhance learning and memory.
And perhaps one of the most potent
of those tools is exercise.
There are numerous studies on this
in both animals and
fortunately now also in humans.
Thanks to the beautiful work
of people like Wendy Suzuki
from New York University.
Wendy's lab has identified
how exercise works
to enhance learning and memory
and other forms of
cognition, I should mention.
As well as things that can augment,
can enhance the effects of exercise
on learning and memory and
other forms of cognition.
Wendy is going to be a
guest on this podcast.
It's actually the episode
that follows this episode.
And it includes a lot of material
that we have not covered today.
And she's an incredible scientist
and has some incredible findings
that I know everyone is going
to find immensely useful.
In the meantime, I want to talk about some
of the general effects
of exercise on learning
and memory that she's discovered
and that other laboratories
have discovered.
If you recall earlier, I mentioned
that learning and memory
almost always involves
the strengthening of particular synapses
and neural circuits in the brain.
And not so much the increase in the number
of neurons in the brain.
There is one exception, however.
And we now have both animal
data and some human data
to support the fact that
cardiovascular exercise
seems to increase what we call
dentate gyrus neurogenesis.
Neurogenesis is the
creation of new neurons.
The dentate gyrus is a
subregion of the hippocampus
that's involved in learning and memory
of particular kinds.
Right, certain types of events,
particular contextual learning,
but some other things as well.
Sometimes involved in spacial learning.
There's a lot debate about exactly what
the dentate gyrus does, but for the sake
of this discussion, and I think everyone
in the neuroscience community would agree
that the dentate gyrus is important
for memory formation and consolidation.
The dentate gyrus does seem
to be one region in the brain,
certainly in the rodent brain,
but more and more it's seeming
also in the human brain
where at least some new neurons
are added throughout the lifespan.
And, as it turns out, that
cardiovascular exercise
can increase the proliferation
of new neurons in this structure.
And that those new neurons, excuse me,
are important for the formation
of certain types of new memories.
There are wonderful data showing that
if you use X-irradiation, which is a way
to eliminate the formation
of those new cells
or other tools and tricks to eliminate
the formation of those cells
that you block the
formation of certain kinds
of learning and memory.
What does this mean?
Well, there are a lot of
reasons for the statement
I'm about to make that extend far beyond
neurogenesis and the
hippocampus learning and memory.
But it's very clear that getting anywhere
from 180, or I should say a minimum
of 180 to 200 minutes
of so called zone two
cardiovascular exercise, so
this is cardiovascular exercise
that can be performed
at a pretty steady state
which would allow you to just
barely hold a conversation.
So breathing hard but not super hard.
Such as in sprints or high
intensity interval training.
But doing that for 180 to
200 minutes per week total
is it appears the minimum threshold
for enhancing some of
the longevity effects
associated with improvements
in cardiovascular fitness
and we believe that it is indirectly,
I should say indirectly,
through enhancements
in cardiovascular fitness
that there are improvements
in hippocampal dentate gyrus neurogenesis.
What does that mean?
The improvements in
cardiovascular function
are indirectly impacting the ability
of the dentate gyrus to
create these new neurons.
To my knowledge there's
no direct relationship
between exercise and stimulating
the production of new
neurons in the brain.
It seems that it's the
improvement in blood flow
that also relate to improvements
in things like lymphatic flow,
the circulation of lymph
fluid within the brain
that are enhancing neurogenesis
and that neurogenesis,
it appears is important.
Now in fairness to the
landscape of neuroscience
and my colleagues at
Stanford and elsewhere.
There is a lot of debate
as to whether or not
there is much if any neurogenesis
in the adult human brain.
But regardless, I think
the data are quite clear
that the 180 to 200 minutes minimum
of cardiovascular exercise
is going to be important
for other health metrics.
Now it is clear that
exercise can impact learning
and memory through other non-neurogenesis,
non-neuron type mechanisms.
And one of the more exciting ones
that has been studied over the years
is this notion of hormones
from bone traveling
in the blood stream to the brain
and enhancing the function
of the hippocampus.
If the words hormones from
bones is surprising to you,
I'm here to tell you that yes, indeed,
your bones make hormones.
We call these endocrine effects.
So in biology we hear
about autocrine, paracrine,
and endocrine.
Those different terms
refer to over what distance
a given chemical has an affect on a cell.
For instance, a cell can
have an affect on itself.
It can have an affect on
immediately neighboring cells
or it can have an affect on both itself,
immediately neighboring
cells and cells far,
far away in the body.
And that last example of a given chemical
or substance having and affect
on the cell that produced it
plus neighboring cells,
plus cells far away
is an endocrine effect.
And a lot of hormones, not
all, work in this fashion.
Hence why we sometimes hear
about endocrine and hormone
as kind of synonymous terms.
Your bones make chemicals that
travel in the blood stream
and have these endocrine effects.
So they're effectively acting as hormones.
And one such chemical is
something called osteocalcin.
Now these findings arrived
to us through various labs
but one of the more important labs
for the sake of this discussion today
is the laboratory of Eric Kandel
at Columbia Medical School.
Eric is now, I believe
in his mid to late 90s,
still very sharp.
And has studied learning and memory.
It also turns out that
he is an avid swimmer.
Now, I happen to know
that Eric swims anywhere
from a half a mile to a mile a day.
And again, this is anecdotal.
I'm not referring to the
published data just yet.
But he credits that
exercise as one of the ways
in which he keeps his brain sharp
and has indeed kept his brain sharp
for many, many decades.
And as I mentioned before,
he's well into his 90s.
So pretty impressive.
His laboratory has studied the effects
of exercise on hippocampal
function and memory.
And other laboratories
have done that as well.
And what they've found is
that cardiovascular exercise
and perhaps other forms of exercise too,
but mainly cardiovascular exercise creates
the release of osteocalcin from the bones
that travels to the
brain and to sub regions
of the hippocampus and encourages
the electrical activity and
formation and maintenance
of connections within the hippocampus
and keeps the hippocampus functioning well
in order to lay down new memories.
Now osteocalcin has a lot of effects
besides just improving the
function of the hippocampus.
Osteocalcin is involved
in bone growth itself.
It's involved in hormone regulation.
In fact, there's really nice evidence
that it can regulate testosterone
and estrogen production
by the testes and ovaries.
And a bunch of other effects
in other organs of the body.
Because again, it's acting
in this endocrine manner.
It's arriving from bone to a lot
of different organs to have effects.
Load bearing exercise, in particular,
turns out to be important for inducing
the release of osteocalcin.
And when you think about
this, it makes sense.
A nervous system exists
for a lot of reasons,
to sense, perceive, etc.
You've got taste, you've got smell,
you've got hearing.
But the vast majority
of brain real estate,
especially in humans, is
dedicated to two things.
One, vision.
We have an enormous amount
of brain real estate devoted to vision.
Certainly compared to other senses.
And to movement.
The ability to generate
course movements of the body.
The ability, excuse me,
to generate fine movements
of the body, like the digits,
or to wink one eye, or to tilt your head
in a particular way, or move your lips
and move your face and do
all sorts of different things
in a very nuanced and detailed way.
So much of our brain real estate
is devoted to movement
that it's been hypothesized
for more than a half century,
but especially in recent years
as we've learned more about the function
of the brain in a really
detailed circuit level,
that the relationship
between the brain and body
and the maintenance and perhaps even
the improvement of the
neural circuitry in the brain
depends on our body
movements and the signal
from the body that our
brain is still moving.
So think about that.
How would your brain know if your body
was moving regularly and how would it know
how much it was moving?
How would it know which
limbs it was moving?
Well, you could say, if the heart rate
is increased then the blood
flow will be increased
and then the brain will know.
Ah, but how does your brain know
that its increased blood
flow due to movement
and not to, for instance,
just stress, right?
Maybe you actually can't move
and you're very stressed about that
and so the increased blood flow
is simply a consequence
of increased stress.
The fact that osteocalcin
is released from bone
and in particular can be released
in response to load bearing exercise.
So this would be running,
again weightlifting
hasn't been tested directly,
but one would imagine
anything that involves
jumping and landing, or weightlifting,
or body weight movements
and things of that sort.
That's a signal to release osteocalcin,
and we know that signal occurs.
That is directly reflective
of the fact that the body was moving
and moving in particular ways.
In fact, you could imagine that big bones
like your femur are going
to release more osteocalcin
or be in a position to
release more osteocalcin
then fine movements like
the movements of the digits.
And this idea that the body is constantly
signaling to the brain about the status
of the body and the
varying needs of the brain
to update its brain circuitry,
is a really attractive
idea that fits entirely
with the biology of exercise, osteocalcin,
and hippocampal function.
I do want to mention that I'm not
the first to raise this hypothesis.
This hypothesis actually was discussed
in a fair amount of detail by John Ratey
who's a professor at
Harvard Medical School.
He wrote a book called, "Spark"
which was one of the early books
at least from an academic
about brain plasticity
and the relationship between exercise
and movement and plasticity.
And John, who I have the
good fortune to know,
has described to me experiments,
or I should say observations of species
of ocean dwelling animals that have,
at least for the early part of their life,
a very robust and
complicated nervous system.
But then these particular animals
are in the habit of
plopping down unto a rock.
They find kind of a safe, comfy space
and they actually stick to that rock
and they don't move anymore
for a certain portion,
I should say the later
portion of their life.
And it is at the transition
between moving a lot
and being stationary that those animals
actually digest their own brain.
The literally metabolize a good portion
of their nervous system
because they decide, oh,
don't need this anymore.
And gobble it up, use it
for its nutritional value
and then sit there like a
moron version of themselves
with a limited amount of brain tissue
because they don't need to move anymore.
Now, I certainly don't
want to give the message
that just moving, just exercise,
is sufficient to keep
the neural architecture
of your brain healthy,
young, and able to learn.
While that might be true,
it's also important to actually engage
in attempts to learn new material.
Either physical material,
so new types of movements
and skills and or new types
of cognitive information.
Languages, mathematics,
history, current events.
All sorts of things
that involve your brain.
Nonetheless, it's clear
that physical movement
and cognitive ability and the potential
to enhance cognitive ability
and the ability to learn
new physical skills
are intimately connected.
And osteocalcin appears
to be at least one way
in which that brain-body relationship
is established and maintained.
So given the information about
osteocalcin and movement,
and given the information
about spiking adrenaline late
or after a period of an attempt to learn,
you might be asking when is
the best time to exercise?
Now unfortunately, that
has not been addressed
in a lot of varying detail,
where every sort of variation on the theme
has been carried out.
And yet, Wendy Suzuki's lab has done
really beautiful experiments where
they have people exercise,
generally it was in the morning.
But at other periods of the day as well.
And what they find is
that at least as late as
two hours after that exercise,
there is an enhancement
in learning and memory.
Now I want to be clear, we don't know
whether or not that exercise led
to big increases in adrenaline.
It may be that those forms of exercise
were modest enough, or didn't
challenge people enough
that they merely got a
lot of blood flow going
and that the improvements in learning
and memory were related to blood flow
and we presume increases in osteocalcin.
However, you could imagine a couple
of different logical protocols based
on what we've talked about.
Let's say you were going
to do a form of exercise
that was going to spike adrenaline a lot.
So this would be exercise
that really challenges
your system and forces you to kind
of push through a burn.
Right, so here I'm mainly thinking about
cardiovascular exercise.
But it could even be yoga,
it could be resistance training.
If it's going to give you a big spike
in adrenaline, it's going
to take some serious effort,
then logically speaking you
would want to place that
after a learning about
in order to increase
learning and memory.
However, if you're using the exercise
in order to enhance blood flow
and to enhance osteocalcin release.
In efforts to augment the
function of your hippocampus,
I think it stands to reason that doing
that exercise sometime within
the hour to three hours
preceding an attempt to learn
makes a lot of sense.
And there I'm basing it on the human data
from Wendy Suzuki's lab.
I'm basing it on the
studies from Eric Kandel
and from others labs.
Again, right now, there hasn't been
an evaluation of a lot
of different protocols
to arrive at the peer-reviewed
laboratory super protocol.
However, since what we're talking about
is using activities
like exercise that most
of us probably, perhaps all of us,
should be doing regularly anyway.
And I do believe most
if not all of us should
regularly be trying to learn
and keep our brain functioning well
and acquire new knowledge.
Because it's just a
wonderful part of life.
And there is evidence
that actually can keep
your brain young, so to speak.
Well then, exercising either before
or after a learning about
makes a lot of sense.
With the emphasis on
after a learning about
if the form of exercise
spikes a lot of adrenaline
for all the reasons we
talked about before.
Okay, so we've talked about two major
categories of protocols to improve memory
that are grounded in quality,
peer reviewed science.
And there is yet another third protocol
that we'll talk about in a few minutes.
But before we do that,
I want to briefly touch
on an aspect of memory,
in fact, two aspects of memory
that I get a lot of questions about.
The first one is photographic memory.
To be clear, there are people out there
who have a true photographic memory.
They can look at a page of text,
they can scan it with their eyes,
and they can essentially
commit that to memory
with very little if any effort.
While it might seem that
having a photographic memory
is a very attractive skill to have,
I should caution you
against believing that
because it turns out that people
with true photographic memory
are often very challenged
at remembering things that they hear.
And often times are not so good
at learning physical skills.
It's not always the case,
but often that's the case.
So be careful what you wish for.
If you do have a photographic memory
there are certain professions
that lend themselves
particularly well to you.
And indeed a lot of people
with photographic memory
have to find a profession
and have to move through life
in a way that is in concert
with that photographic memory.
So again, it's a super ability,
it's a hyper ability and
yet it's not necessarily one
that is desirable for most people.
There's also this category
of what are called
super recognizers.
These people are, I should mention,
highly employable by government agencies.
These are people that have
an absolutely astonishing
ability to recognize faces and
to match faces to templates.
They can look at a photograph
of say somebody on a most wanted list
and then they can look at video footage
of let's say an airport, or a mall,
or a city street at fairly low resolution
and they can spot the person who's face
matches that photograph
that they looked at.
Even if that video or other footage
is of people's profiles or even
the tops of their heads and just
a portion of their forehead.
These people have just
an incredible ability
to recognize faces and to template match.
And again, these people often will take
jobs with agencies where this
sort of thing is important.
Some of you out there probably
are super recognizers and
may or may not notice it.
If you've ever had the experience
of watching a movie and
thought to yourself,
wow, her mouth looks so
much like my cousin's mouth.
Or you look at a character in a movie
or a television show and you think,
wow, they look almost like the
younger sister of so and so.
Well, then it's very
likely that you have this,
or at least a mild form of
this super recognizer ability.
That is not memory per se.
That is the hyper functioning of an area
of the brain that we
call the fusiform gyrus.
The fusiform gyrus is literally
a face recognition area, and
a face template matching area.
And it harbors neurons that
respond to faces generally.
So as humans and other non-human primates,
we care a lot about faces
and their emotional content.
And the identity of faces
is super important to us
for all the kinds of reasons
that are probably obvious.
Knowing who's friend, who's foe.
Who do you know well?
Who's famous, who's not famous?
Etc.
That is not memory, per se.
And yet, if you're a super recognizer,
or I guess you could call it
a moderate face recognizer
or not very good at recognizing faces
because indeed, there are some people
that are kind of face blind.
They don't actually recognize people
when they walk in the room.
I used to work with somebody like this.
I'd walk into his office and he'd say,
are you Rich or are you Andrew?
And I would say, well am I rich, rich.
Like, you know, wealth rich?
No.
And he'd say, no, are you
Richard or are you Andrew?
And I'd say, I'm Andrew.
We know each other really well.
And he'd say, oh I'm sorry.
I'm kind of face blind.
And it actually tended
to be better or worse
depending on how much he was working.
Ironically, the more rested he was
the more face blind he would become.
So it wasn't a sleep deprivation thing.
That exists, that's out there.
There's the full constellation
of people's ability to recognize faces.
That's not really memory.
And yet, visual function is
a profoundly powerful way
in which we can enhance our memories.
So whether or not you're a
super recognizer of faces,
whether or not you are face blind
or anything in between.
Next I'm going to tell you about a study
which points out the immense
value of visual images
for laying down memories.
And you can leverage this information
and this involves both
the taking of photographs,
something that's quite easily
done these days with your phone.
As well as your ability
to take mental photographs
by literally snapping your eyelids shut.
So I just briefly want
to describe this paper
because it provides a
tool that you can leverage
in your attempt to learn
and remember things better.
The title of this paper
is Photographic Memory,
the Effects of our Volitional Photo-Taking
on Memory for Visual and Auditory
Aspects of an Experience.
I really like this paper because it refers
to photographic memory not in the context
of photographic memory
that we normally hear about
where people are truly photographic,
look at a page and somehow
absorb all that information
and commit it to memory.
But rather the use of camera photographs
or the use of mental camera photographs.
Literally looking at
something deciding, blink,
snapping a, so to speak,
snapping a snapshot
of whatever it is that you are looking at
and remembering the content.
The reason I like this paper
and the reason I'm attracted to this issue
of mental snapshots is this is something
that I've been doing since I was a kid.
I don't know why I started doing it,
but every once in a while, I
would say maybe twice a year
I would look at something
and decide to just
snap a mental snapshot of it.
And I've maintained very clear memories
of those visual scenes.
Two years ago I was in an Uber
and I looked out the window
and it was a street scene.
I was actually in New York at the time
and I decided for reasons
that are still unclear to me,
to take a mental snapshot
of this city street image.
Even though nothing interesting
in particular was happening.
And I do recall that
there was a guy wearing
a yellow shirt walking, there
was some construction, etc.
I can still see that
image in my mind's eye
because I took this mental snapshot.
This paper addresses whether or not
this mental snapshotting thing is real
and this is something I think a lot
of people will resonate with,
whether or not the constant taking
of pictures on our phones
or with other devices
is either improving or
degrading our memory.
You could imagine an argument for both.
A lot of people are taking pictures
that they never look at again.
And so in a sense, they're outsourcing
their visual memory of
events into their phone
or some other device and they're not ever
accessing the actual image again.
They're not looking at it, right?
You're not printing out those photos.
You're not scanning
through your phone again.
Sometimes you might do that,
but most of the time people don't.
Most of the photographs people are taking
they're not revisiting again.
So the motivation for this study was that
previous experiments had shown that
if people take photos of a scene
or a person, or an object, that
they are actually less good
at remembering the details of that scene
or object, etc.
This study challenged that idea
and raised the hypothesis that
if people are allowed to choose what
they take photos of, that taking photos,
again, this is with the camera,
not mental snapshotting.
That taking those photos would actually
enhance their memory for those objects,
those places, those people, and in fact,
details of those objects,
places, and people.
And indeed, that's what they found.
So in contrast to previous studies
where people had been more or less told,
take photos of these following objects,
or these following people,
or these following places
and then they were given a memory test
at some point later.
In this study people were given
volitional control, right?
They were given agency in making
the decision of what to take photos of.
And I'll just summarize the results.
We'll provide a link to this study.
I should say that some of the stuff
that they tested was
actually pretty challenging.
Some of them were pottery and other forms
of ceramics that are of
the sort that you see
if you go to a big museum in a big city.
And if you've ever done that,
and you see all the different objects,
there are a lot of
details in those objects
and a lot of those
objects look a lot alike.
And so someone will have two handles.
Some will have one handle.
The position of the handles.
How broad or narrow these things are.
You know, a lot of this
is pretty detailed stuff.
They also took photos of other things.
So basically what they found was that
if people take pictures of things
and they choose which things
they are taking pictures of, right.
It's up to them, it's volitional.
That there's enhanced memory
for those objects later on.
However, it degraded their ability
to remember auditory information.
So what this means is that when we take
a picture of something, or a person,
we are stamping down a
visual memory of that thing.
And that makes sense, it's
a photograph after all.
But we are actually inhibiting our ability
to remember the auditory,
the sound component
of that visual scene or
what the person was saying.
Very interesting.
And points to the fact
that the visual system
can out compete the auditory system,
at least in terms of how the hippocampus
is encoding this information.
The other finding I find
particularly interesting
within this study is that it didn't matter
whether or not they ever
looked at the photos again.
So they actually had people take photos,
or not take photos of different objects.
They had some people keep their photos
and they had other
people delete the photos.
And it turns out that whether or not
people kept the photos
or deleted those photos
had no bearing on whether or not
they were better or worse
at remembering things.
They were always better
at remembering them
as compared to not taking photos of them.
What does this mean?
It means that if you really
want to remember something
or somebody, take a photo
of that thing or person.
Pay attention while you take the photo.
But it doesn't really matter if you look
at the photo again.
Somehow the process of taking that photo,
probably looking at it.
You know, in a camera typically we'd say
through the viewfinder or now
because of digital cameras
on the screen on the back of that camera,
or on your phone, that
framing up of the photograph
stamps down a visual image in your mind
that is more robust at serving a memory
then had you just looked at that thing
with your own eyes.
Very interesting and it raises all sorts
of questions for me about whether or not
it's because you're
framing up a small aperture
or a small portion of the visual scene.
That's one logical interpretation,
although they didn't test that.
I should also say that they found
that whether or not that you looked
at a photo that you took,
or whether or not you deleted it
and never looked at it again,
didn't just enhance visual memory
or the memory from the visual
components of that image
but it always reduced your ability
to remember sounds associated
with that experience.
So that's interesting.
And then last but not least,
and perhaps most
interesting, at least to me,
was the fact that you didn't even need
a camera to see this effect.
If subjects looked at something
and took a mental
photograph of that thing,
it enhanced their visual
memory of that thing
significantly more than had they not taken
a mental picture.
In fact, it increased
their memory of that thing
almost as much as taking
an actual photograph
with an actual camera.
And the reason I find this so interesting
is that a lot of what we
try and learn is visual.
And for a lot of people,
the ability to learn visual information
feels challenging.
And we'll look at something and we'll try
and create some detailed
understanding of it.
We'll try and understand the relationships
between things in that scene.
It does appear based on this study
that the mere decision to
take a mental snapshot,
like, okay I'm going to blink my eyelids
and I'm going to take a snapshot
of whatever it is I see,
can actually stamp down a visual memory
much in the same way that
a camera can stamp down
a visual memory.
Of course, through vastly
distinct mechanisms.
No discussion of memory would be complete
without a discussion of the
ever intriguing phenomenon
known as deja vu.
This is a sense that we've
experienced something before
but we can't quite put our finger on it.
Where and when did it happen?
Or the sense that we've
been someplace before.
Or that we are in a
familiar state or place
or context of some kind.
Now, I've talked about
this on the podcast before,
at least, I think I have.
And the way this works has been defined
largely by the wonderful
work of Susumu Tonegawa
at Massachusetts Institute
of Technology, MIT.
Susumu collected a Nobel
Prize, quite appropriately,
for his beautiful work on immunology.
And he's also a highly
accomplished neuroscientist
who studies memory and
learning and deja vu.
And I should also mention
the beautiful work
of Mark Mayford at the Scripps Institute
and UC San Diego.
Beautiful work on this notion of deja vu.
Here's what they discovered.
They evaluated the
patterns of neural firing
in the hippocampus as
subjects learn new things.
Okay, so neuron A fires,
then neuron B fires,
then neuron C fires in
a particular sequence.
Again, the firing of neurons
in a particular sequence
like the playing of keys on a piano
in a particular sequence leads
to a particular song on the piano
and leads to a particular memory
of an experience within the brain.
They then used some
molecular tools and tricks
to label and capture those neurons
such that they could go back later
and activate those neurons in either
the same sequence or
in a different sequence
to the one that occurred during
the formation of the memory.
To make a long story short,
and to summarize multiple papers
published in incredibly
high tier journals,
journals like Nature and Science
which are extremely stringent,
found that whether or not
those particular neurons
were played in the precise sequence
that happened when they encoded the memory
or whether or not those neurons
were played in a different sequence,
or even if those neurons were played,
activated that is, all at once
with no temporal sequence.
All firing in concert all at once,
evoked the same behavior.
And in some sense, the same memory.
So at a neural circuit
level, this is deja vu.
This is a different pattern of firing
of neurons in the brain leading
to the same sense of what happened,
leading to a particular
emotional state or behavior.
Whether or not this same
sort of phenomenon occurs
when you're walking down the street
and suddenly you feel as if, wow,
I feel like I've been here before.
You meet someone and you feel like,
gosh I feel like I know you.
I feel like there's some familiarity here
that I can't quite put my finger on.
We don't know for sure
that's what's happening
but this is the most mechanistic
and logical explanation for what
has for many decades, if
not hundreds of years,
has been described as deja vu.
So for those of you that
experience deja vu often,
just know that this
reflects a normal pattern
of encoding experiences and events
within your hippocampus.
I'm not aware of any
pathological situations
where the presence of deja
vu inhibits daily life.
Some people like the sensation of deja vu.
Other people don't.
Almost everybody, however, describes it
as somewhat eerie.
This idea that even though you're in
a very different place, even
though you're interacting
with a very different person,
that you could somehow
feel as if this has happened before.
And just realize this,
that your hippocampus,
while it is exquisitely good at encoding
new types of perceptions, new experiences,
new emotions, new
contingencies and relationships
of life events, it is not infinitely large
nor does it have an infinite bucket full
of different options
of different sequences
for those neurons to play.
So in a lot of ways it makes perfect sense
that sometimes we would feel as if
a given experience had
happened previously.
I'd like to cover one additional tool
that you can use to improve
learning and memory.
And I should mention, this is
a particularly powerful one
and it's one that I'm definitely
going to employ myself.
This is based on a paper from none other
than Wendy Suzuki at New York University.
We talked about her a little bit earlier.
And again, she's going
to be on the podcast
in our next episode.
And is just an incredible researcher.
I've known Wendy for a number of years
and it's only in the
last, I would say five
or six years that she's really shifted
her laboratory toward generating protocols
that human beings can use.
And she's putting that to great effect,
great positive effect I should say.
Publishing papers of the sort
that I'm about to describe.
But also incorporating some of these tools
and protocols into the learning curriculum
and the lifestyle curriculum
of students at NYU.
Which I think is a terrific initiative.
So you don't need to be an NYU student
in order to benefit from her work.
I'm going to tell you
about some of that work now
and she'll tell you
about this and much more
in the episode that follows this one.
The title of this paper
will tell you a lot
about where we're going.
The title is Brief Daily
Meditation Enhances
Attention, Memory, Mood,
and Emotional Regulation
in Non-Experienced Meditators.
If ever there was an
incentive to meditate,
it is the data contained
within this paper.
I want to briefly describe the study
and then I also want to emphasize
that when you meditate
is absolutely critical.
I'll talk about that just at the end.
This is a study that involves
subjects aged 18 to 45.
None of whom were experienced
mediators prior to this study.
There were two general
groups in this study.
One group did a 13 minute long meditation
and this meditation was a
fairly conventional meditation.
They would sit or lie down.
They would do somewhat of a body scan,
evaluating for instance
how tense or relaxed
they felt throughout their body
and they would focus on their breathing.
Trying to bring their attention
back to their breathing
and to the state of their body
as the meditation progressed.
The other group, which we
can call the control group
listened to of all things, a podcast.
They did not listen to this podcast.
They listened to Radio Lab,
which is a popular podcast,
for an equivalent amount of time.
But they were not
instructed to do any kind
of body scan or pay
attention to their breathing.
Every subject in the study
either meditated daily
or listened to a equivalent
duration podcast daily
for a period of eight weeks.
And the experimenters
measured a large number
of things, of variables, as we say.
They looked at measures
of emotion regulation.
They actually measured
cortisol, a stress hormone.
They measured, as the title suggests,
attention and memory and so forth.
And the basic takeaway of this study
is that eight weeks but not four weeks
of this daily 13 minute a day mediation
had a significant effect in improving
attention, memory, mood,
and emotion regulation.
I find this study to be very interesting
and in fact, important because most of us
have heard about the positive effects
of meditation on things
like stress reduction.
Or on things such as improving sleep.
And I want to come back
to sleep in a few moments
because it turns out to
be very important feature
of this study.
This particular study I like so much
because they used a really broad array
of measurements for cognitive function.
Things like the Wisconsin
Card Sorting Task.
I'm not going to go into this.
Things like the Stroop Task and they also,
as I mentioned, measured cortisol.
And many other things, including,
not surprisingly, memory.
And people's ability to
remember certain types
of information, in fact
varied types of information.
And the basic takeaway was, again,
that you could get really
robust improvements
in learning and memory, mood and attention
from just 13 minutes a day of meditation.
Now there's an important
twist in this study
that I want to emphasize.
If you read into the
discussion of the study
it's mentioned that somehow meditation
did not improve but actually
impaired sleep quality
compared to the control subjects.
And you might think,
wow, why would that be?
I mean, meditation is
supposed to reduce our stress.
Stress is supposed to inhibit sleep.
And therefore why would sleep get worse?
Well, what's interesting
is the time of day
when most of these subjects tended
to do their meditation.
Most of the subjects in this study
did their meditation late in the day.
This is often the case in experiments.
I know this because we run experiments
with human subjects in my laboratory
and people are paid some amount of money
in order to participate
or they're given something
as compensation for being in the study.
But often times the meditation,
or in the case of my
lab, the respiration work
or other kinds of things
that they're assigned to do
are not their top, top priority.
And we understand this.
But in this study, the
majority of subjects here
I'm reading completed
their meditation sessions
from somewhere between 8:00 and 11:00 P.M.
And sometimes even between
12:00 and 3:00 A.M.
I think there probably were a lot
of college students
enrolled in this study.
And their hours often are late shifted.
That impaired sleep.
And this raises a bigger theme
that I think is important.
Many times before on this podcast
and certainly in the episode
on mastering sleep and
conquering or mastering stress
those episodes we talked
about the value, again,
of these non-sleep deep
rest protocols, NSDR,
for reducing the activity
of your sympathetic nervous system.
The alertness, so-called stress arm
of your autonomic nervous system.
The one that makes you feel really alert.
NSDR is superb for reducing
your level of alertness,
increasing your level of calmness,
and putting you into a so-called more
parasympathetic, relaxed state.
Meditation does that too, but
it also increases attention.
If you think about meditation,
meditation involves
focusing on your breath
and constantly focusing
back on your breath
and trying to avoid the distraction
of things you're thinking or
things that you're hearing.
And coming, so-called, back to your body,
back to your breath.
So meditation is actually,
it has a high attentional load.
It requires a lot of
prefrontal cortical activity
that's involved in attention.
Which then logically relates
to one of the outcomes of this study
which is that attention ability
is improved in daily meditators.
It also points out that increasing
the level of attention and the activity
of your prefrontal cortex may,
and I want to emphasize may,
because here I'm speculating
about the underlying mechanism,
inhibit your ability to fall asleep.
So while we have
meditation on the one hand
that does tend to put us into a calm state
but it is a calm, very focused state.
In fact, attention and focus are inherent
to most forms of meditation.
Non-sleep deep rest, such as Yoga Nidra
as some of you know it to be.
Or NSDR, there's a terrific NSDR script
that's available free online
that's put out by Madefor.
So you can go to YouTube, NSDR, Madefor.
You can also go do a search for NSDR.
There's a number of these
available out there,
again, at no cost.
Those NSDR protocols tend to put people
into a state of deep relaxation
but also very low attention.
And we have to assume very low activation
of the prefrontal cortex.
So the takeaways from this
study are several fold.
First of all, that daily meditation
of 13 minutes can enhance your ability
to pay attention and to learn.
It can truly enhance memory.
However, you need to do that
for at least eight weeks
in order to start to
see the effects to occur
and we have to presume
that you have to continue
those meditation training sessions.
In fact, they found
that if people only did
four weeks of meditation
these effects didn't show up.
Now eight weeks might
seem like a long time,
but I think that 13 minutes a day
is not actually that big
of a time commitment.
And the results of this study certainly
incentivize me to start adopting a,
I'm going for 15 minutes a day now.
I've been an on and off
meditator for a number of years.
I've been pretty good about it lately,
but I confess I've been
doing far shorter meditations
of anywhere from three to
five, or maybe 10 minutes.
I'm going to ramp that
up to 15 minutes a day.
And I'm doing that specifically to try
and access these improvements
in cognitive ability
and our abilities to learn.
Also based on the data in this paper,
I'm going to do those meditation sessions
either early in the day, such
as immediately after waking,
or close to it.
So I might get my sunshine first.
I'm, as you all know, very
big on getting sunlight
in the eyes early in the day.
As much as one can and
as early as one can.
Once the sun is out.
But certainly doing it early in the day
and not past 5:00 P.M. or so
in order to make sure that
I don't inhibit sleep.
Because I think this, the
result that they describe
of meditation inhibiting quality sleep
compared to controls is an important one
to pay attention to.
No pun intended.
Today we covered a lot
of aspects of memory
and how to improve your memory.
We talked about the
different forms of memory
and we talked about some of the underlying
neural circuitry of memory formation
and we talked about the emotional saliency
and intensity of what
you're trying to learn
has a profound impact on
whether or not you learn
in response to some sort of experience.
Whether or not that experience is reading,
or mathematics, or music, or
language, or a physical skill.
It doesn't matter.
The more intense of an
emotional state that you're in
in the period immediately
following that learning,
the more likely you are to remember
whatever it is that
you're trying to learn.
And we talked about the neuro chemicals
that explain that effect.
About epinephrine and
corticosterones like cortisol.
And how adjusting the timing of those
is so key to enhancing your memory.
And we talked about the different ways
to enhance those chemicals.
Everything ranging from
cold water to pharmacology
and even just adjusting
the emotional state
within your mind in order to stamp down
and remember experiences better.
We also talked about how
to leverage exercise,
in particular, load bearing exercise
in order to evoke the release of hormones
like osteocalcin which can travel
from your bones to your brain and enhance
your ability to learn.
And we talked about a new
form of photographic memory.
Not the traditional type
of photographic memory
in which people can remember everything
they look at very easily.
But rather, taking mental snapshots
of things that you see.
Again, emphasizing that will create
a better memory of what you see
when you take that mental snapshot,
but will actually reduce your memory
for the things that you
hear at that moment.
And we discussed the really exciting data
looking at how particular
meditation protocols
can enhance memory but
also attention and mood.
However, if done too late in the day,
can actually disrupt
sleep precisely because
those meditation protocols
can enhance attention.
Now I know that many of you are interested
in neuro chemicals that can
enhance learning and memory.
And I intend to cover those in deep detail
in a future episode.
However, for the sake of
what was discussed today,
please understand that any number
of different neuro chemicals can evoke
or can increase the amount of adrenaline
that's circulating in your brain and body.
And it's less important how one accesses
that increase in adrenaline.
Again, this can be done
through behavioral protocols
or through pharmacology.
Assuming that those behavioral protocols
and pharmacology are safe for you,
it really doesn't matter how you evoke
the adrenaline release because remember,
adrenaline is the final common pathway
by which particular experiences,
particular perceptions
are stamped into memory.
Which answers our very
first question raised
at the beginning of the episode.
Which is, why do we
remember anything at all?
Right, that was the
question that we raised.
Why is it that from morning 'til night
throughout your entire life you have tons
of sensory experience,
tons of perceptions.
Why is it that some are remembered
and others are not?
While I would never want to distill
an important question such as that down
to a one molecule type of answer,
I think we can confidently say based on
the vast amount of animal
and human research data
that epinephrine, adrenaline,
and some of the other chemicals
that it acts with in concert, is in fact,
the way that we remember particular events
and not all events.
If you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to our podcast
on Spotify and on Apple.
And now on both Spotify and Apple
you can leave us up to a five star review.
Please also leave us comments and feedback
in the comment section
on our YouTube channel.
You can also suggest future guests
that you'd like us to cover.
We do read all those comments.
Please also check out
the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of today's podcast.
That's a terrific, perhaps the best way
to support this podcast.
We also have a Patreon.
It's patreon.com/andrewhuberman.
And there you can support this podcast
at any level that you like.
During today's episode and
on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them.
For things like enhancing sleep and focus
and indeed, for learning and memory.
For that reason the Huberman Lab Podcast
is now partnered with
Momentous Supplements.
The reason we've partnered with Momentous
is several fold.
First of all, we wanted
to have one location
where people could go to
access single ingredient,
high quality versions of the supplements
that we were discussing on this podcast.
This is a critical issue.
A lot of supplement companies out there
sell excellent supplements
but they combine different ingredients
into different formulations
which make it very hard to figure out
exactly what works for you
and to arrive at the
minimal effective dose
of the various compounds
that are best for you.
Which we think is extremely important
and that's certainly
the most scientific way
and rigorous way to approach any kind
of supplementation regime.
So Momentous has made these
single ingredient formulations
on the basis of what we suggested to them
and I'm happy to say, they
also ship internationally.
So whether or not you're
in the US or abroad,
they'll ship to you.
If you'd like to see the
supplements recommended
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
you can go to LiveMomentous.com/Huberman.
They've started to
assemble the supplements
that we've talked about on the podcast
and in the upcoming
weeks they will be adding
many more supplements such
that in a brief period of time
most, if not all of the compounds
that are discussed on this podcast
will be there, again,
in single ingredient,
extremely high quality formulations
that you can use to arrive
at the best supplement protocols for you.
We also include behavioral protocols
that can combined with
supplementation protocols
in order to deliver the maximum effect.
Once again, that's
LiveMomentous.com/Huberman.
And if you're not already
following us on Twitter
and Instagram, it's HubermanLab
on both Twitter and Instagram.
There I describe science
and science related tools.
Some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is distinct
from the content of the
Huberman Lab Podcast.
We also have a newsletter called
the Huberman Lab Neural Network.
That newsletter provides summary protocols
and information from our
various podcast episodes.
It does not cost anything to sign up.
You can go to HubermanLab.com,
go to the menu
and click on newsletter.
You just provide your email
and I should point out,
we do not share your
email with anyone else.
We have a very clear privacy policy
that you can read there.
And that newsletter comes
out about once a month.
You can also see some sample newsletters.
Things like the toolkit for sleep,
or for neural plasticity and for various
other topics covered on
the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Once again, thank you for joining me today
to discuss the neurobiology
of learning and memory
and how to improve your memory using
science based tools.
And last, but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[light music]